Oh welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Marvin
holy [ __ ] welcome to this emergency
session of fat man beyond where we can
talk about the Captain Marvel trailer my
god but before we get there how you been
I've been all right man you got it in
one
fat man beyond you I did I don't need
help anymore yeah nice job now I don't I
because I just smoked too so it should
have smoked away but but I was present
the whole time I was walking from the
back I'm like fat man beyond fat man
beyond fat man Vienna it is I'm sorry
we're starting so late that's that's on
me although you were late - yes well I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on in
town we can't blame this one on Quentin
Tarantino the Hollywood Bowl is doing a
big show I know they are because donnell
rawlings my co-star and Halle weed
texted me this morning to be like do you
want to come to the Hollywood Bowl to
see me Chappelle Lauryn Hill De La Soul
and I was like what the [ __ ] like I just
woke up to the greatest offer ever and
then I saw on Twitter like somebody
wrote captain Marvel's been up for an
hour and you haven't reacted and I was
like everything about today is good like
everything's coming up millhouse and
then I forgot we have a show yeah sorry
so I couldn't go to that [ __ ] show so
I had to tell him my gosh yet I can't go
so that's what's happening under the
bowl so Chappelle [ __ ] up traffic but
I don't know what's going on down here
why it was so clogged Lauryn Hill is
also notoriously late for [ __ ] so the
show might not have started it might not
start for another huh I may be able to
get done with this show go to that show
it's did she have a reputation she does
really yeah yeah for just like the show
starts when it starts coming all artists
like that though yeah I guess but you
know color people time also plays in
there a little bit what
I don't even know if you're allowed to
say that anymore I tried to my
grandfather my grandfather was born in
1900 the [ __ ] serious yeah he's since
passed because otherwise he'd be like
the [ __ ] oldest person in the world
500 1819 but he was just old enough to
like I got on well with your fancy radio
and your color television and your
phones in every room of your house but
he would never stop referring to black
people as coloured real that was just
his thing because that's what for a
better and most likely for worse people
had called him for his entire life
so trying to break that I was like you
know granddad we're afro-americans NASA
as [ __ ]
also I don't believe in dinosaurs which
he didn't believe in it there's a lot to
unpack here babe
but let's table the race issue for a
moment to just be like why he why
doesn't he believe in dynasty his
rationale was I don't believe anything
that big ever actually walked on the
earth well because if they did where'd
they go and I'd be like well comets
granddad likes this [ __ ] nature did
some shape like aha
don't buy it said what do you think is
in the museum Natural History which you
took me to and we walked under the giant
[ __ ] skeletons like I hands off
[ __ ] hooks also moon landing didn't
believe it at all these [ __ ] really oh
my god your granddad would have been so
at home right now the world her of the
Internet man he would be like I knew I
was right look at all these people who
believe me he's like why go all the way
up there for what are you gonna get and
I was that grandma I don't know you're
right what did they get that's where all
the dinosaurs went so bad to bring some
facts I had some progress I don't
believe it all right fine it's all good
by the way we're not colored anymore
my grandfather was the other guy white
as [ __ ] and had zero problem using the
word colored back then either man sad to
say but he was an angry dude he was a
boxer like he had been a professional
boxer it actually is in the boxing hall
of fame has like a record and [ __ ] like
that had a belt belted somehow some
relative of ours has his belt and then
he married my grandmother and then the
you know the story when I was growing up
was like grandma made him quit boxing
and for some reason I just like you know
I was a kid all the way up to fairly
recently I bought it I was just like I
guess like you know she was like that
ain't safe you shouldn't do it but I
like when I'm not a boxer but I - I'm
like I'm gonna get in front of people
for a living I cannot do a real thing I
don't do a real job it's like a make
pretend job and boxing sports is the
same kind of thing getting paid to play
something that's not curing cancer or
something it's a pastime it's an
entertainment of sorts and stuff so I
understand the idea of like being up in
front of people and the idea of not
being up in front of people anymore and
if it's true that my grandmother was
just like I want you to stop boxing
think about it dude you were in the ring
you [ __ ] punch somebody the [ __ ] out
and everyone's like and suddenly you're
gonna give that up because your wife's
like no I don't like that and you're
like okay like you were a boxer used to
rock people in the mush for a living and
[ __ ] so suddenly as I got older Master I
think about Isaac that's just [ __ ]
it ain't as simple as like she told him
to retire and he retired the story
behind the story and they're all dead so
I can't back this up is my grandmother
had the magic [ __ ] man because in order
to get that guy to be like I will leave
behind the godhood of in the ring like
where I'm a champion I have a [ __ ]
belt and just because she's like get out
of the ring she must have had something
going on man where he's like you don't
know what she could do since she's a
finger up the ass the magic swirl all of
Italy
mean what was this is like the 20s or
30s or something all she probably had to
do was like here's a little ass he was
like [ __ ] box saying that like I will be
entertained at home yeah as the only
ways was sued that savage beast but yeah
he was also because he didn't box
anymore he was always so damn hostile
not to me but I remember him like in
traffic he was [ __ ] yelling at
everybody he was a guy that would just
[ __ ] yellow people and he had a
fishhook under his [ __ ] yeah under you
know like I know what you did last
summer he had that under the [ __ ] car
so like one time we were driving up to
the city and [ __ ] we got into an
altercation on the Garden State Parkway
like [ __ ] some traffic and he [ __ ]
pulled over the other guy pulled over
the other guy gets out of the car my
grandfather gets out with this giant
[ __ ] hook the other guy gets in his
[ __ ] car my grandfather chases the
car down the Parkway my grandmother's
yelling get in the car Dixie and [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that his name wasn't even
Dixie that is the weird thing so yeah he
was a pretty [ __ ] it was pretty
pretty rough dude yeah my grandfather
didn't tell the story once about this
crazy white man it chased him with
officials oh my god in the TV movie of
our lives it started there dissolve to
later years lady yes front of people at
a bar see how far we've come
grandfathers the Defiant ones - oh my
god alright what else were we talking
about what was i up to I'm leaving
tomorrow I go up to Vancouver to shoot
Supergirl so I'll be gone for a little
while
yes looking very forward to that but did
I read on Twitter are you doing
something here at the canteen and I
absolutely think I might do a thing
because I tell talk about the thing and
then I'll give you props for the title
do it go ahead yeah I think I think
maybe on the 2nd of October I'm gonna do
I'll hold it down and we'll just do a
special Castle Rock themed episode of
black man beyond black man that is
branding of the highest order of my
friend I thought that was adorable so
you'll do like the show like you did
with the roundtable yeah a little bit
but just me I think I'm I solo you're
gonna [ __ ] rock the mike beier Sam I
trying rock it by myself and I'm not
even gonna be here to see it
it'll be on the Internet's though oh
that's true watch it later on it and if
I was here I would just join you and be
like hi yeah this is weird
yeah that's not saying anything for two
hours could you imagine I was like
sitting there just watching you the
whole time so you're gonna go up solo
and just see if I can find a guest who
may or may not have had something to do
with the show right
um buddy I'll talk a little bit of how I
got there what the experience was like
and then answer any lingering questions
that I can answer about what the [ __ ]
happened at the end of that season is
there question like is there a lot of
people is it like the end of loss going
what the [ __ ] a little bit a little bit
there's some there's some open-ended
things that happen at the end of that
that I can what better oh you're sweet
but yeah so yeah that's what we'll do I
think well I will keep the home fires
burning for you while you're up in the
great white north [ __ ] and I and then
next week you're coming up to the great
window or a show that we're doing at the
Rio Theatre up there which is really
[ __ ] fun that'll be fun doing a show
away from here here [ __ ] which we forgot
to key in on man ladies and gentlemen we
are as always right here in the heart of
the scum and villainy Cantina on
Hollywood Boulevard in Hollywood
California put your hands together
I applaud that that's why that's awesome
we should have a good time
if not I'll never do it again yeah no
but they were so mean to me without days
it's the one the same thing at all
standing there all sad by myself like I
hope not don't oh it sounds like you've
sold three tickets I know you're a well
on your way if the only people to show
up I'll just go sit over there
amazing man show with a three-man
audience and stuff when I had a panel at
comic-con this past year the one that I
got my inkpot award at yeah spotlight
panel and and I was telling a buddy of
mine that I was a little concerned that
nobody would be there and he told me the
story of this author who would always
keep a $20 bill in his pocket every time
you hold a reading or signing whatever
and he'd go there and he'd say if enough
people show up that I could buy each of
them a drink with the $20 in my pocket
that's what we'll go do and if not if
there's more people then we'll do
whatever have a reading of signing
whatever it was so that's how it's gonna
be on the second like if enough people
show up that I could buy you all the
drink with twenty bucks
we'll just do that we're in a [ __ ]
bar yes there is we'll have a little a
little soiree be amazing the very
intimate show around one of those tables
and the booth yeah hey guys you'll be
like that scene from Star Wars where
they met that guy in a space dog I
speaking of which I just re-watched Solo
did you yeah I had a good ass time
watching at home it's available on like
iTunes I imagine other forms of [ __ ] I
don't know if it's on blu-ray yet but
like I watched it on iTunes [ __ ] fun
as [ __ ] watching it on yeah and
expectations are lower that you're in
the comfort of your own home no but I
liked it at the theater too so for me
it's just like oh I knew I was right it
was more like that I'd be curious to see
you take a look again cuz again I didn't
hate it at all no neither of us did okay
but it was after the other day we did a
show on Batman day
you went through the article we're ready
Jonathan chasm was the was talking about
like here's some highlights and stuff
and he shouted out the scene of Han in
the cockpit for the first time mm-hmm
and I couldn't remember if it was the
first time ever or the first time he
slips behind the captain's chair or
whatever the [ __ ] but I watched both of
those scenes pretty closely and like
they're pretty good I think
I hope he's talking about the first time
on walks into the cockpit because there
definitely was like that felt more
emotional it felt like there is the the
music kind of quietly swelled and [ __ ]
like that but hands down the Chewie
scene is the finest hour of that movie
it's a really like wonderful
meet-cute scene the fact that he's like
that he could speak his language and
shin it was really kind of a cool idea
something that I never thought of
because we've never seen him once in the
movies be looks like he just talks to
him and [ __ ] like he understands him and
then speaks English Adam this is the
first time that he's busted wookie at
him but now it makes Han Solo feel like
a little bit more of a dick though and
that he never speaks to Chewie in his
native language ha ha ha figs that
wookie were more serious like you're
speaking [ __ ] why don't you say
something
now you do all the [ __ ] work space
dog see that's the solo movie everyone
wanted it's a city you know ha [ __ ] too
chewy and chewy bitching it on like an
old married couple and [ __ ] like that
why you make me talk in this language
okay Yap man but it's so I you know
definitely worth of watch I want to be
uh I'm just gonna say this I thought it
would go without saying I thought I
never had to say this but I saw a tweet
today because I've retweeted you know
the the [ __ ] trailer for Captain
Marvel and talked about how I dug and
[ __ ] like [ __ ] take every nickel a
half Marvel and there was like a couple
people like most people here [ __ ]
right [ __ ] cab well said later I
still the Promised Land like you know
everyone on the same page but a very
small percentage about five tweets of
people going like how much are they
paying you to say this [ __ ]
are you shilling for marble and I just
want to [ __ ] and go on the record as
saying like you're crazy if you think
marvel has to pay anybody to say
something nice about them or to hit
people to movies that are coming
particularly to an audience that's
pre-sold
like I hey I'll just flat out deny it
I'll be honest like nobody [ __ ] pays
me to say nice things if they do I will
let you know I just like to talk about
the [ __ ] I like talk about and that was
that [ __ ] trailer I'd done I was like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] hey I can't wait and I
guess like some people if they don't
react to it they think like you must be
paid by these pools
I'm just enthusiastic I swear to you I
don't get any [ __ ] money they don't
have to pay me that's the beauty of
[ __ ] fandom man they figured out a
long time ago like oh my god we
harnessed the fanbase they'll do all the
work for us
I'm just a little more high profile or
vociferous than the average [ __ ] bear
but no [ __ ] nobody's ever given me a
dime to say any nice things ever say any
of the things I say you hear about the
[ __ ] that I love I love talking about
the [ __ ] I love you know you never hear
about [ __ ] that I hate or the [ __ ]
that's like man meant nothing to me or
whatever like that so when you see me
sucking the dick of something and you're
like oh my god how much are they paying
him they're not I'm just that [ __ ]
stupid so they're the for the record I
would like to say that I haven't been
paid to say anything nice about anything
but I would take the money if they start
paying [ __ ] for [ __ ] I'll take
that money
I'm just hoping like to get invited to a
premiere or get a free ticket but that's
not even why I say anything I say
because I I like it like I like doing
this podcast because it's not about my
life like smart guess about me and my
world and and James and Bob get old is
also kind of about me and my world and
stuff Hollywood babble-on
and this are like I get to talk about
the [ __ ] that I like long before I was
like a person that made [ __ ] I was just
a fan and if I'd never made something
guess what I'd be a [ __ ] fan so like
this is in a weird way this show allows
me to get back to the guy I was before I
had a
we're and that guy gave me that career
type look as I thought about it a lot
I'm like why [ __ ] do you go out like on
a [ __ ] weekday night and stand in
front of strangers and talk about [ __ ]
that's not yours like in a world of
branding and selling that doesn't make
[ __ ] sense you're selling somebody
else's stuff but it's not about selling
somebody else's stuff it's just about oh
my god isn't this [ __ ] cool because
that's what I used to do before I had a
job so like now that I have a job and
[ __ ] worked out and I found a family and
I lived happily ever after
now I get to circle back and [ __ ] do
the same [ __ ] I was doing before I had
to get busy doing all that so I I just
love talking about this [ __ ] I don't do
it cuz somebody pays me you know pays me
Weight Watchers and I'm very clear about
that like I'm a Weight Watchers
ambassador and they didn't they didn't
just see if there was no you know king
or queen that dubbed me that out of
nicety and [ __ ] like that that I'm I'm
paid to talk about Weight Watchers when
I talk about weight and stuff like that
but I have to put that up if I put that
up you know something with tweet or an
Instagram
I put ad and [ __ ] if you don't see ad on
it like that's just [ __ ] I like man it's
just me trying to jump into the
conversation same [ __ ] I'd be doing if I
didn't have the job I had if I worked
there quick stop still in the age of the
Internet
I'd be on my [ __ ] phone being like
did you see Captain Marvel because just
like everybody else I - I'm looking for
a distraction from the fact that one day
I'm gonna [ __ ] die and I got close
this year so now Captain Marvel trailer
seems even better than it would have pre
heart attacks I'm like you [ __ ] don't
know I saw the grave you know and very
dramatic so so yeah I was just like to
clear that up I saw a few tweets of
people going like you're a shill I'm
like I mean the shield gets paid I just
do it for the love yeah I'm also looking
for distractions and these days more
than most days ever
from [ __ ] like hey why is toad trending
on Twitter I saw that I woke up this
morning a Mario Cart he was 20 on
Twitter I was like what
[ __ ] happened did Mario Kart die like
organ Mario Kart you know [ __ ] like
say something racist or be to somebody
like why is mario kart trending and then
I found out why I was trining I was just
like so that's what his dick looks like
and the best part was Nintendo put out
this tweet which was like hey we see
Mario Kart and toda trending yay all
guys ha ha ha
Oh sweetheart you just don't know yes
yes to read one that was like when
Castle Rock I always feel bad about this
when their official Twitter account when
they first like started up and running
and we do had a premiere date in the
first trailers around and they put some
like in turn some young schmuck any
schmuck on their social media feeds
reaching out to influencers about the
show and so I get this tweet it's like
hey we see that you like things like
film and genre can I tell you a little
bit about castle rock I was like I don't
mean today I mean to break it to you but
I know about it already read the bio and
then that I got start getting emails
from like Hulu PR like oh [ __ ] we are so
sorry because that sweet went to like
retweeted a thousand times and my show
on his column is like hey could you like
not blow up our own social feeds online
lady it's like just JJ doesn't see this
[ __ ] tweet or you will never work in
this town again and it's almost got
there hey can we tell you about Castle
Rock no but can I tell you about castle
rock I know where the whole season is
going let me tie how it ends oh all
right enough with the [ __ ] [ __ ] Chad
you got news I got a [ __ ] Captain
Marvel trailer man that's before the
news that is before we get to the news
let's do the breaking news the most
important news
ladies and gentlemen I woke up this
morning and a Captain Marvel had
happened all over the world by way of
Good Morning America brie Larson got on
and introduced students from the Air and
Space Museum or something tying in very
closely of course to have a Carol
Danvers characters origins and they
released the trailer yes
and see part as part of Good Morning
America like everyone else I saw it as
part of the Twitter feed or anywhere
else online and stuff it is look my
heart my heart soared but my ego
plummeted in the toilet when I saw them
go her hero I've been on this best of
all possible worlds forty eight years
and never saw that coming it never saw
oh my god if you just put an O on her it
says hero like [ __ ] the special effects
that got me like I was like oh my god
that's [ __ ] breathtaking and [ __ ]
brilliant add to it it opens with you
know [ __ ] her to the main character
falling through the sky into the roof of
a video store and I was just like I used
to work in one of those this feels very
personal it's just my story the 90s I
might be in this oh my god we waited to
see who was gonna save us from Thanos
and [ __ ] and they finally gave us a
glimpse my favorite image in the trailer
other than like a single image there's a
little triptych of images that is very
powerful which I imagine we'll talk
about but single shot was they have her
wearing the helmet with the glowing
[ __ ] eyes I took a screenshot of that
and put it up on my laptop because it's
like it teared [ __ ] like that
does it for me man like that took me
right into the comic book that took me
to my childhood I was like that looks
[ __ ] up and wonderful and perfect and
I can't believe we're in the world of
glowing eyes on [ __ ] helmets now like
oh my god everything about this is
fantastic so so many key moments I was
seeing
Nick Fury age 12 like never mind you
know he's got two eyes like we know that
Marvel de-aging process [ __ ] like works
we've seen it for little dollops in you
know what Iron Man know a horror and
what was the other one
ant-man an ant-man but little dollops
because it's [ __ ] expensive if he's
as big as a character as the trailer
let's on every single shot of him is an
expensive effect shot and it looks like
they're going for broke like everything
looks be honest I got all the money so
they could [ __ ] do it and [ __ ] but
it's literally like any time they show
him they got to dial him back to the Sam
Jackson from what looks like Sam Jackson
from maybe like circa jungle fever like
it's that young yeah its jungle fever
without the beard man like I was looking
at him going like holy [ __ ] he looks
[ __ ] young Agent Coulson
mmm-hmm looks about the same age yeah
just like some three more three more
hairs on his head the the fact that they
are telling a story where she doesn't
seem to remember they're doing the
amnesia thing of like I think I had a
life here is intriguing they haven't
done that yet in the Marvel movie so
that means they're not going to do a
traditional origin story we're not gonna
see her blah blah blah she's gonna piece
it together as the audience is piecing
it together so that's exciting and they
haven't really done that yet that I can
think of in one of those Marvel movies
seeing her in the end of the trailer of
course being the costume that everybody
knows was absolutely [ __ ] thrilling
all of it man then go into space we've
seen the image of of the scrolls in you
know Entertainment Weekly and there's a
brief flash of them yeah which leads to
like you know if you're a comic book fan
a great moment in the trailer ruling
Captain Marvel rocks an old woman in the
face just like and that you know you're
like oh [ __ ] she just [ __ ] it out in a
scroll but people that don't know comics
are like why is she hitting on elderly
women on the subway
but I'm intrigued you know yeah I I
loved it and you know once again like I
was happy to see it's like [ __ ] March
cuz that's like two months before
infinity war what a like double [ __ ]
nut punch that's gonna be man where it's
like there's Captain Marvel and just
when we're not even done with the
Captain Marvel conversation when all of
a sudden they're like here's what
happened all the heroes that died you
know and we get to see the end of that
story can't [ __ ] wait what was your
take on the trailer I mean all the
things you said apply and they're all
true and they're all wonderful the thing
that that gripped me the most was
there's there's a series of shots to
triptychs of shots of carol danvers as a
girl and as a like sort of Air Force
trainee and as what seems to be a Kree
warrior falling down and then the same
sort of shots of her in those same time
periods standing up and then just that
right now where we are when we are in
the world where we are socially and and
gender-wise the fact that the
iconography of this seems to be standing
up and I clenching your fist and getting
after it it reminds me a little bit of
in the Wonder Woman trailer like when
she climbs up the [ __ ] thing into
no-man's land the power yeah absolute
power but giving props to that Wonder
Woman trailer yeah that was everything
like as much as this Captain Marvel
travel the trailer is wonderful but I
believe they're calling it a like teaser
trailer something like that but that the
and this is not putting it down that
Wonder Woman trailer was [ __ ]
transcendent for that moment I mean it's
a movie it's a moment right out of the
movie but they were so smart to put that
in the [ __ ] trailer because it just
[ __ ] took your your legs out from
under and your breath away and still
totally but it seems as if part of the
iconography part of this symbolism of
these movies is standing up yeah I'm
getting ready to fight because it's a
[ __ ] fight now apparently every other
week it's a fight for something we
didn't know we were fighting for and
watching women have to endure the slings
of arrows of a life but standing up
against it and fighting for it and just
[ __ ] gritting your teeth and staring
into the wind and taking it
like that's super [ __ ] powerful yeah
and really really moving and as
contemporary as anything could be that's
also seems to be generated to be
somewhat eternal like it is a movie of
today wrapping its arms around all of
this sort of myth making of 30 40 years
where the comic book storytelling I
loved it today while being set in the
90s totally yeah and that too is also an
interesting approach of like oh right on
[ __ ] like that we haven't seen that
yet or we've seen flashbacks but a movie
set in that period they show there were
little flashes they show the beeper not
the same one from the end of infinity
war but there's one that has a distress
message that's like holy [ __ ] that's
it's it's got to be part of it
Jude Law very briefly in the trailer why
why do you think what do they hide I'm
not sure I'm not Jesse Marvel who do you
think so
could be but is that it's confirmed he
is Marvel so what are they not why only
like a brief image of him in the trailer
because the rest of the movie he looks
like classic Marvel he's a scroll trying
to be Marvel does she punch him in the
face
had better yeah it's it's he they're
keeping them out of the they're not
they're not leaning on but all going
look we got [ __ ] Jude Law like
they're selling Marvel which is another
thing you watch that trailer it's not
even like brie Larson the [ __ ] movie
star brie Larson like she's definitely
Captain Marvel she looks amazing as
Carol Danvers but they're not selling
the movie on her there's not selling the
movie on Jude Law there's some movie on
the character it is not where there's
trailers that's starring these people
okay to me Award nominee samuel
l.jackson bloody bloody blah no it is
just here is this [ __ ] that you want
here's all that you're here for it's
also it has the world they have the
world so [ __ ] trained that they're
like it doesn't even [ __ ] matter you
know you have to see this to see the
next Avengers movie
so [ __ ] you and take it but who wouldn't
want to see it man it's like right now
like it's it's we're gonna see some
history and marvel like it's weird that
they didn't start with a black widow
movie that would have seemed logical but
hey man if I get you I bet you by the
time we're done watching cap tomorrow
would be like well [ __ ] that was the way
to give a female character of their own
movie in the Marvel Universe or
something like that man not just not to
just be a part of it but you ultimately
save for the Marla universe I mean
that's kind of beautiful yeah like at
the end of the day that's true that's
what we're being set up for it's like we
know for a fact without her [ __ ]
whatever happens in Avengers Ford
doesn't get to happen so Marvel helps
ant-man get out of the quantum zone
that's your guest Kevin Feige that's for
the people at home that's a good [ __ ]
guy do you know that are you just
putting that together theory I like your
theory I want to pay to see your movie
sir
afterwards please all right yeah man
[ __ ] once again they've done it like
[ __ ] they just they just tee it up
they know how to [ __ ] sell it was so
smart to start with a blockbuster cuz
every like right away the whole [ __ ]
world goes wait something's wrong you
know I remember that but it's been a
minute so and then there's a bunch of
kids who are just like what is that
you know they've never seen a
blockbuster it's it's the equivalent of
on like Microsoft Word the save icon is
still a floppy disk yeah haha yeah it's
still like and it's one of those shitty
like hard ones like a whatever somebody
sounds like what is that supposed to be
that's a disc but what did it do it's
what you saved [ __ ] on why
you would like move this [ __ ] from
computer to computer than Java email no
all right update that then all we had
was history son and we were a living
part of no dinosaurs though we talked to
granddad they never existed all right so
yeah once again again marvel zone what's
the next comic book trailer we rode we
got a first Aquaman trailer so they'll
probably be a second Aquaman trailer
Joker they're starting to shoot now so
it'll be a long time if you see that
trailer the image of what gives that
part of the news in as much as there was
a picture of him right let's save that
for the news before we dive into the
news there's one other trailer that
dropped today that I thought was really
[ __ ] great of course it wasn't gonna
get the attention that Captain Marvel
got they made a movie about Laurel and
Hardy in their later years called stan
and Ollie and it stars Steve Coogan as
Laurel and [ __ ] john c reilly in an
almost like unrecognizable you know
[ __ ] prosthetic playing hardy the old
hardy late in their lives when they went
over to England and started doing a
stage show and [ __ ] and they thought
movie looks [ __ ] fantastic man yeah
like you know vert I was never like when
I was a kid Laurel and Hardy would be on
in syndication and stuff but my dad of
course like he'd always be like watch
these guys they're hysterical and I
would always even at age five be like
dad they're dead
but he grew up watching them instead it
was yours a laurel and hardy house or an
Abbott and Costello house because well
heels really both like you could do both
yeah yeah my dad definitely liked both
and definitely he leaned more toward
Laurel and Hardy because like they it
was mostly quiet
like it wasn't dialogue-driven and [ __ ]
but he looked respected them both and he
also liked the [ __ ] dead-end kids
which I when I was a child then they
came on they the Bowery Boys the
dead-end kids they had like 40 year olds
playing teenagers and even me as a
five-year-old I'm like this is sick
like so I only went so far with the old
man all right we did you watch the Emmys
did you I did I only watch the part that
everybody talks about when the the
director of the Oscars won an Emmy and
used that most beautiful moment ship
where he was like my mom you know passed
away two months ago and she loved my
girlfriend and I love my girlfriend and
[ __ ] you know you know she's like why
why don't you ever call me your
girlfriend is like because I want to
call you my wife and the whole [ __ ]
place lit up man and it was genuine
because that place is full of liars
right so of course they're all
programmed to be like must put on happy
emotion selfie but instead they [ __ ]
genuinely reacted like the same I've
seen people like live propose and other
settings and [ __ ] and the audience does
freak the [ __ ] out like as almost as if
people are taking their clothes off the
Holly [ __ ] we're saying something real
here and it was beautiful he brought
that lady up funny and gave her a ring
that was his mom's and [ __ ] he was a
true showman and even said to the
director of the Grammy or the the Emmys
like you got to give me a minute here
man like here's talking shop to the guy
and the guy gave him full [ __ ] time
because these are not like famous people
so you'd imagine they'd be like play
these [ __ ] off but it was so magical
and it seemed like the highlight of the
evening and she
yeah just shut the [ __ ] house just
rocked it man [ __ ] brought the house
down shut the house she brought the
house down yeah the rest of the show was
not that exciting they didn't have that
happening every 15 they should have oh
just [ __ ] take people off the street
who's got a girlfriend yeah really
really like or you would love get in
here man do you have a ring we'll give
you one that's fine yeah I mean I
suppose as a nerd it was good to see
Game of Thrones win for Best Drama is
they did they did is that the first time
no no but it's always nice so they did
it again yeah although the place that I
work that is totally not where they are
doing post on Game of Thrones
they had a lovely sort of celebration we
overheard from where our office was it's
like what are you doing upstairs like I
think there's an Emmy up there oh good
for them could we see some of this now
fine
Congrats [ __ ] we like cake - you
gotta get up - some of them off for
shenanigans you see in [ __ ] [ __ ]
where you guys stay after hours break
into the Game of Thrones side of things
and take their [ __ ] Emmy man
and then like take their [ __ ] like
what you do is you take their Emmy and
they're all like where's the [ __ ]
Emmy and [ __ ] and then a day later you
sneak back in you leave the Emmy and you
leave a [ __ ] camera like one of those
instapoll awards that you send a way to
develop do they still make those anymore
disposable cameras for blackmail and you
leave the camera there and then they're
like what's with the camera and they
gotta get it developed and then when
they get it developed and then looking
through the pictures is a picture of the
Emmy in your ass
and you're like Game of Thrones I thirst
we're gonna go we just send back pieces
of the enemy one by one like there's one
of the little [ __ ] lightning bolts
and like big load do you want the rest
of it would you be more mad if somebody
stole your Emmy busted into the pieces
and sent it back to you or stole it
put it back then you develop the camera
and saw that it was in their ass I think
I could crazy glue an Emmy back together
like that I'm going a scam all the way
cuz it's not like I'm gonna get the Emmy
back and be like oh you've been missing
when when when when he's gonna let it
sit right there I was like it was gone
now it's back st. Anthony found it you
know I'm [ __ ] move on but whatever you
like to stick it in your ass - yeah it's
when everybody leaves and [ __ ] and I'd
look at all the pictures and I'm like
what a coincidence we have so much in
common what else happened on that show
Tandy Newton from Westworld oh I saw
that speech where she goes I don't even
believe in God but I'm gonna thank her
tonight yeah I was a classy line and she
I thought that was funny good for her
man she's awesome on that she released
season 1 I haven't seen season 2 but
season 1 she was amazed yeah Peter
Dinklage won he's always amazed he's
gonna he's always gonna win these things
yeah he should and legit should and
that's not just like as a game of
Thrones bent like he's a fantastic actor
the USS Callister episode of black
mirrors oh that one yeah that's writing
for a limited series that was Charlie
wrote that himself you know a broker and
deep deep deep in the [ __ ] categories
which they don't air on the broadcast
yeah but Rick and Morty won for Best
Animated Series oh [ __ ]
for the pickle Rick episode oh the only
one I've ever [ __ ] seen is the one
that won an Emmy it's an amazing episode
yeah it's it is probably like I love
Rick and Morty and watch it religiously
and I've watched every episode multiple
times but I honestly think pickle Rick
might be a the most rewatchable episode
because you're like holy [ __ ] look at
how he kills that rat like anything
because they kill so many of them yet it
goes by you're like holy [ __ ] by the
time you get to your 20th viewing a
pickle Rick and [ __ ] you're like I can't
believe you've ripped that one's [ __ ]
head off and then you pause it and you
call muse and you know like come over
let's watch this together you know so
and that's also the most shareable
episode yes where you're like hey watch
watch this like to somebody who's never
I don't understand Rick and Morty like
just [ __ ] watch this this will tell
you this story that's great man it's a
wonderful creative imaginative episodes
nice to hear they give out awards for
[ __ ] I like - yeah and I think Robot
Chicken also won an Emmy for Best Short
formula and boys and girls wow that's
awesome [ __ ] the geeks didn't hair these
did all right yeah okay so when I get
into and the Fonz
yes Henry Winkler I saw he won for Barry
the bear that show was wonderful did you
watch it I haven't seen a single it is
really good I watched it like whatever
good great things it's really it's it's
its own you know honestly like this is
not the highest compliment I could pay
something but it feels like an
independent movie to me like not a
series it's shot each episode is like an
indie film he directed a bunch of the
episodes I think the first two or three
been really great job like and I don't
mean really great job like all I
directed himself well great composition
stunning composition where I was like oh
[ __ ] that's a great way to frame a shot
why did I never think of that because
I'm not a great filmmaker like Bill
Hader apparently like so I did I liked
it quite a bit and he's wonderful in it
I mean when is [ __ ] Henry Winkler not
wonderful but he's really great in the
show and his art was actually enjoyable
and fun for him and [ __ ] so he won for
that yeah that's supporting actor and
then he read a speech from did I
understand like I've read something
online he read the speech that he had
prepared when he was like nominated back
in the 70s
so the speech like at the end of it he
was like go to bed boys and his boys are
like 50 that's what I heard I hope that
was true and stuff but I saw a picture
that he put up on Twitter of him and Ron
Howard oh and it was like there was like
that's my childhood there's the Fonz and
richie cunningham together like you know
obviously looking older but it was so
adorable that they like you know when i
saw them together like they like they
shared so much time like not only that
they've been in rest of development
together and stuff they've been friends
for years but they shared this
monumental time in their lives which is
long since gone and they both way moved
past it and stuff but they they live
together in for lack of a better
description happy days Martha and here
they are years later as old men smiling
at a picture is really really sweet what
else anything else windows that's about
it unless you love the marvelous missus
Mazal which seems to win everything did
that win a bunch of awards yeah it's a
show about a lady in the 50s it becomes
a comedian right which I've never seen
but I hear it's lovely by the lady who
did any sherman-palladino Gilmore Girls
this is on their what second season now
yes yeah I'm gonna dive in man like that
sometimes it takes me a minute to catch
up but like it does keep winning awards
so it must be definitely worth a spin
all right good for all those [ __ ]
people at the Emmys man and people that
punched and didn't get punched at the
Emmys I guess but let's move on man mark
barnard inhere used to be entertainment
journalist and then he was an editor of
some of this nation's finest periodicals
including Los Angeles Times and stuff so
he certainly [ __ ] knows how to find
the news and what he's deal it from
other people yeah it's a long way to say
I'm mark went to the internet and pulled
up some [ __ ] stories for us to talk
about and that's what we're gonna do the
first part of the show man as we talk
about the news give it up for Mark
Barnard he sniffed out some news
and this is a tricky [ __ ] feet cuz we
just did a show on like Saturday yeah so
Sunday Monday it's Tuesday night how
much news could have [ __ ] happen
other than Captain Marvel hey have you
heard about this hot young director
named Brian singer I yeah I believe he
made that Keyser söze picture he did he
did he also made some x-men movies yeah
oh that's right he also lived under a
cloud of suspicion over rape of young
boys which yeah there was there was a
bit of a hullabaloo over parties he may
or may not have thrown at his house that
may or may not have had underage people
there may or may not have had sex he
also seems to not like to hang out on
the movie sets for the movies he's
directing you've heard that as well yeah
he got a [ __ ] off from Bohemian
Rhapsody and was replaced by an actor
because he decided he just didn't want
to be there anymore is that the story
that that seems to be what happened he
just stopped showing up and there was
also some talk of that might have
happened on one of the x-men movies that
is unfounded so don't sue me for libel
I'm just spreading rumors which is
probably not a good idea but yes at the
very least this is the last episode of
fat man The Alibi
I've just received a text from Bryan
Singer's Lord but but yes he is he's had
some troubles as of late but he still
keeps getting work apparently including
the new Red Sonja movie that millennium
films was putting together
were you a Red Sonja fan I mean I'm not
like you know but like I wasn't even a
big Conan fan I like the Conan movie of
course but I didn't like I wasn't a big
comic onin comic book fan or pour into
the literature or anything and so you
know and I like you know I saw Conan
when they made the movie I saw both
Conan's at a theater paid to see him
with my own lawn mowing [ __ ] money
and then when Red Sonja come out I
almost went to see it because you know I
remember back then we were like
Oh Nan's in it oh [ __ ] I want to go but
you know then I didn't wind up doing it
until it got to Home Video that's where
I finally start yeah and Schwarzenegger
was in it but not playing Conan the
Barbarian that's right that was the
thing he wasn't playing don't have the
rights to it yeah but it's a it's a
pretty interesting character and Gail
Simone has written a comic book that
dynamite put out for a while yeah
dynamite has a very successful run of
that comic book recently yeah but it and
and a friend of at least me if not the
show Ashley Miller who co-wrote x-men
first class and co-wrote Thor with Zack
Stemmons real friend of the show two
wonderful movies wrote the script and
they seem to be making this movie and I
just can't quite understand how one
continues to work when that is your
problem seems to be not working that
much and why you wouldn't get a female
director to make you a Red Sonja that to
me is the bigger question like I thought
we lived in that world now where it was
just like look if you're doing Batgirl
shouldn't it be written by a woman and
directed by a woman like I thought we're
living in a post Wonder Woman
world at this point so it would be
strange it's just strange to hear that
somebody's like hey we got an insanely
empowered female driven project the
character of fantasy and fiction and she
like I'm not saying she's up there with
Wonder Woman but like to somebody who
doesn't give a [ __ ] about this stuff you
could be like red Sun you know she's
kind of like Wonder Woman
you know she you know I've kind of got a
medieval thing she's got shield and a
[ __ ] knife or a sword or whatever the
[ __ ] like there's an easy parallel to
[ __ ] make so we saw what happened
there and what the formula was for
success you just imagined whoever's
making Red Sonja be like yeah let's
let's get a woman and direct this
because well begun is half done and [ __ ]
like that or if you're not gonna get a
woman maybe get a dude that's not this
dude I know all the dudes you could
choose this is the dude you choose who's
making my movie millennium the guys they
did all the Expendables movies
yes you seem like you have thoughts no
no I mean it works [ __ ] work right
like and at the end of the day why is he
gonna ask because his names on a list of
people that know how to make a hundred
million dollar or more movie and you
know I guess he's get a bowl right now
for those guys for Millennium according
to this story which broke in The
Hollywood Reporter
sources say millennium will pay singer
top dollar for the assignment which is
seen as a step towards rehabilitating
the Directors image Singh was fired by
Fox after repeatedly not showing up for
work on the set of its Queen biopic
Bohemian Rhapsody among other work
offences in December he was sued by
Cesare Sanchez Guzman who accused the
director of raping him when he was 17
year old boy in 2003 it wasn't the first
time that singer had faced such an
accusation
so yeah let's give that dude some work
too acid tongue yeah Wow well uh
Hollywood never seems to mystify and Wow
yeah yeah go on to the next one you want
to marinate in those juices for a while
those juices don't taste good to me
let's get on to something else I mean I
don't know a the the you know there's a
lot of time packed there but the biggest
news is or to me the biggest takeaway is
why the [ __ ] wouldn't you hire a woman
to direct that like that is an absolute
[ __ ] no-brainer never mind then you
don't even have the conversation of do
you really want this person directing
you're like right think about whatever
the [ __ ] it just seems like the obvious
answer is right there and instead you
know somebody's like now let's do it the
old ways and I don't know if you're
gonna last that long anymore in this or
any other business looking to do it the
old ways I'm probably not probably did
you ever watch Avatar The Last Airbender
no not like you did you watched every
episode and stuff I've watched the
episode more than once you've seen it a
couple of times it's it is if I was nine
years old today it would be the Titanic
work of fantasy in my life what compared
to something from our childhood like
it's the blank of our if it's the Harry
Potter I was a man when that happened
all right I don't want to do this but
it's the it's the Lord of the Rings of
our trial now I'm out that's your
problem right my bad so it's [ __ ]
like it's great if this this vast world
that's all about what is it the Star
Blazers Astra boy that was more episodic
right it wasn't one long adventure it's
the Star Blazers was an aqua off to
outer space we're leaving Mother Earth
to save the human race our Star Blazers
I remember the rascals I mean that's
enough thank you but it's big bigger
than that it's because it's it's because
all I remember about Star Blazers the
theme song to be honest is but you seem
to remember everything about Airbender
and you like it as a storyteller as just
a person who appreciates [ __ ] cartoon
as a storyteller yeah it's it's for real
drama and it does amazing character work
it's one of the best
rehabilitations of a villain I've seen
in a long time within the story within
the story like they they they give you
this one character name's Prince Zuko
who begins eyes like I am the [ __ ]
evil son of a Fire Lord and all I want
to do is kidnap the avatar and blah blah
blah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and it
over the course of three seasons you're
watching this guy struggle with his fate
with his destiny with the choice to be
the man that he wants to be it is a more
complex version of what we should have
done with Darth Vader but never did
it sounds kylo Ren --is-- but then again
they went after a betray so maybe kylo
Ren sounds a little what's this guy's
name as you go maybe sounds a little
Danny's a little bit little they're
singing and dancing gold bracelet
only the movie folks danny zuko does not
sing greased lightning in the grease
play just a little bit of trivia for
those of you who are like I've always
wanted to go see the greased play and
then you see Kenickie stand up and sing
greased lightning and you're like what
the [ __ ] happened they changed it for
the movie moving on from grease I'm not
sure what to now tell me more tell me
more
oh my god you saved my grease mitt
thank you brother thank you which I I
was never that big a fan of grease until
you get to tell me and it's still not a
big fan of race I hated it once you get
to the tell me more tell me more when
it's like oh no this is about date rape
you saw that in 1977
I remember watching when they did it on
in Fox NBC which everyone did the
[ __ ] live version right oh wait a
second I don't like young girls like
this [ __ ] musical it's the worst
[ __ ] story if you're a girl yeah a
date rape bead here's the lesson you
should maybe be what the boy wants you
to be instead of being who you really
are in order to get him for a summer
does that motherfucker's go in someplace
else and it's a triumph when she [ __ ]
shows up in the black leather even
though she's not that girl but I'm doing
it for this guy who's patently an
[ __ ] it's true it's true and he's
like look I put on a school sweater for
you and she's like tell me about it stud
and he's like [ __ ] this sweater and then
he looks exactly like he's look the
whole movie so he didn't give up
anything nope not even close
you're absolutely [ __ ] right I just
want to point out for the record if
you're playing the fat man beyond bingo
at home mark has used the word rape
three times this evening which is a
susana the amuse bouche after the color
it's true your taboos all right where
else can we hit anyway Netflix is making
a live-action Avatar The Last Airbender
show all right now as a fan yes well all
right we'll hold that thought okay M
night Shyamalan did something like that
in movie form but everyone agreed that
it was not yes the worst thing in the
world okay not the worst thing in the
world you know clothes rape and racist
okay so trigger your steps really holy
[ __ ] so so it's so in your mind can this
be done it can be especially because
they got the two creators of the cartoon
to come back oh that's more an executive
produce and run and write of this new
show if they're smart they're just like
here's the old scripts do this with
money yes and they are they're committed
to and one of the the cardinal offenses
of M night Shyamalan movie aside from it
being shitty was that it sort of
whitewashed all of the characters away
from being Asian because the story is
set in yes it's fictional but it's in a
fictional Asian world in which all of
these characters are sort of adhering to
this sort of kind of Asian mysticism set
in like it's a fantasy place but all
these characters are brown people and a
night Shyamalan a brown dude it was like
you know what I really want white people
except for the bad guy who will make
Asian it's like oh man was his was it
the same bad guy character what's his
name Prince Zuko Zuko again Patel yeah
how was he not good it would be great if
like that was the one dude who like
figured out how to make it happen no he
wasn't the stealing K Brown that's true
high honors yeah all right so you feel
like they can I feel like there's
actually a world in which Netflix is
making everything and spending all the
money on all the [ __ ] but if they spent
the money on this then sometimes the
programming comes out of Netflix and I
mean you know [ __ ] they're doing
great work over there the Lord's work
even but there are so many [ __ ]
programs and there's sometimes there's
such weird like really like that you
just imagine Netflix like current-day
Netflix is run by a bunch of people in a
boardroom in the 80s who are like what
if I we did a live laugh last airbender
like like not the [ __ ] cartoon but
everybody's real like real like they
aren't a show and the real and they're
bending air and [ __ ] like that and Danny
Zuko is there let's [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
you know my favorite game is Marco Polo
we should do a show called Marco game
it's about actual [ __ ] Marco Polo
Marco Polo Marco money do it [ __ ]
breathe let's go you know we need
[ __ ] told more episodes of iron fist
now I want you to [ __ ] tape it'll be
[ __ ] great you know you get daughters
in the [ __ ] dragon it'll [ __ ] love
doors good harshing my buzz man you can
support those two [ __ ] episodes up
your [ __ ] nose really doing [ __ ]
tennety good for them and they are Megan
they get some of the ballsiest de sensee
they're making some of the ballsiest
decisions over there thank you Netflix
theatres autumn and brought to you by
cocaine and Ford Motor Cars and they're
practically irresponsible use of
hundreds of millions of dollars I
applaud the man they're making
entertainment like they know something
we don't
like as if somebody took them into like
the [ __ ] Oval offices of the world is
ending in ten years and they're like
let's just make everything except
whatever Kevin Mark bitcha ASSA truly
Wow all right so you recommend the first
time or should do the animated version I
would it's it's lovely and especially if
you've got somebody under the age of 18
or 40 or 260 in your house yeah I think
they would love it to death
beautiful yes I'm fair enough but it's
coming and we can't stop it is you don't
seem I would I'm not I'm embracing it
all right although I will also say that
I was once on the record saying hey you
know what
I welcome three Hobbit movies I loved
[ __ ] three Lord of the Rings movies
that guy makes good pizza you're telling
me he wants to make more pizza and he's
giving me another slice of [ __ ] pizza
I'm gonna take that [ __ ] slice of
pizza and I didn't want any slices of
those beats on second time around he was
like here's vegan pizza
my god I guess yeah all right are we
done with that story we are done with
that story let's move on to another
story all right
Marvel Comics oh love them yes they are
doing a kill monger miniseries oh [ __ ]
yeah because duh the big well because
they made that a the storytellers Ryan
Coogler & Co made and especially Michael
B Jordan made that character so [ __ ]
compelling like you know the character
comes from comics but [ __ ] they made a
version of kill manga where like I'd
watch more of that and and you know
spoilers he's dead although could he
come back after infinity war III don't
know yeah that's when the [ __ ]
Superman comes to Marvel and spins the
world backwards and the earth spins off
his access into the [ __ ] Sun and we
all die okay that's my Marvel DC
crossover everybody dies issue 1 alright
so kill monger the comic I'm Emily the
comic
they're also doing cherie comic oh right
uh yeah because I mean why not like
we've got a bunch of people out there
who are now wave well-versed in the
Black Panther universe like give me no
characters and they date alone books
yeah they're doing a black another black
panther cartoon which is another yeah
Reggie Hudlin did one till 2011 I think
that was on B et that nobody [ __ ]
watch did you ever see it I watched an
episode of it I think and it's okay it's
it was right for another one right
especially right now absolutely totally
and I'm not sure why I don't know more
about it because I should know
everything about a black panther TV show
but Marvel seems kind of quiet about
telling people that they have a black
panther TV show it's not out yet no but
like next week it's about to break yeah
oh really the Disney XD show I visit the
Disney XD they do one of the spider-man
cartoons as well that makes sense
absolutely yeah
why wouldn't you do that but yes kill
monger is coming written by a Brian
Edward hill who's done some pretty
interesting work on a book called postal
for top cow and he's just gotten into
the bat family he he wrote a run on
detective ooh yeah
so yeah sharp guy all right I meant kill
monger there it is run to the comic book
stores look if you like these movies and
TV shows you always got to remember that
came from somewhere so totally honor the
source material oh one more [ __ ] kill
mugger
yes buy a comic so Mark Ruffalo did some
press and talked a little bit about how
[ __ ] up the processes for making
Avengers 4 do tell I will spill the tea
mark we're doing research starting in
September it says Ruffalo wait this
September yes like now reshoots reshoot
so they're changing things it's not just
these aren't pickups this isn't like
they wrapped that movie yeah but now
they're like hey man we're gonna make
the story different or better why do you
think like you know at least according
to Ruffalo they hadn't made final
decisions yet on a bunch of [ __ ] in the
movie I hope they're not second-guessing
themselves like that [ __ ] last
picture was wonderful I've watched it
again since the last time we recorded
man [ __ ] it's fantastic yeah I mean
it's it's it's silly they're like you
know how we got to that first one lots
of reshoots like maybe that's the way to
do it eration for now and just figuring
[ __ ] out we're doing reshoots showing in
September then we'll go back into the
international tour then you guys will
get the second installment which we
don't even know what it's going to be
yet we're not just doing reshoots we're
gonna finish the movie which we really
didn't get to finish totally when we
left it last year all right well there
you go yeah Ruffalo indicated directors
Anthony and Joe Russo are still figuring
things out I don't even know that they
really know exactly Ruffalo said I'm
sure they're not happy he said this
because some of it is happening while
we're there it's pretty amazing and
we'll shoot some stuff and a few days
later come back and reshoot it because
we want to take it another direction
it's a very living organism even as we
approach it being a locked picture we're
still working on it
we're getting dummy scripts that really
blew my mind because I didn't I because
I was like you have to really let to go
out of your way to give everybody
that isn't quite what's gonna happen
some of us I think didn't even know what
we were watching until we were actually
watching it finished Wow yeah
I heard what's her name is a Carrie [ __ ]
[ __ ] the one who plays the not racist
that's her name is that really yeah I
just want to clarify you got to remove
that chip if you put it on fat man be on
bingo the season so she somebody said
that they saw her in an interview or
something like that and she said that in
the room like on the like green screen
they were like look there and stab
something and she was like what am I
looking at her stabbing they're like we
don't know you know so like they're you
know it sounds like since a lot of it
isn't done in post most of the magic is
created in post and in that character
performance that's more motion capture
than anything else in there moving at a
clip you know it sounds like they are
figuring out some things along the way
but [ __ ] if that's if if infinity war is
an example of people figuring out [ __ ]
as they go along that's far better than
my best prepared has ever been so if
they're still figuring it out now I
[ __ ] trust them I trust those guys
implicitly man with my life even just
because they've made a couple good
[ __ ] movies but those movies are real
[ __ ] good yeah so I mean it's they're
making it it's out next [ __ ] May but
they just seem to be tweaking how many
months they got September October
November December January February March
April May so eight months until we see
that picture it's about seven months
until they have to be completely locked
I can lock up into the last day so it's
between seven and eight months yeah all
right I don't got if they're if they
feel the need to reshoot or if it's
based on the fact that like wow we
didn't quite finish the movie they know
what they're doing so far they have not
dropped the ball and also it must be
like a tall order to follow infinity war
and the reaction to it like it really
captured people's imagination the
[ __ ] snap and like what happened all
those
characters and blah blah blah is real
haunting movie for a blockbuster or
summer blockbuster so I guess maybe like
you know maybe there's a part of them
somewhere on the team or they're like
how do we maybe what we had prepared
ain't good enough for the ending like we
should dial it up a notch or something
like that I don't I don't know man I'm
the guy that's like that's good enough
moving on like we would have been done
with the Avengers movie in my world like
two years ago and sure so I but I trust
they know what they're doing because the
end results so far have been stellar
I have faith me too all right what else
we got that's all we got that's all the
news it's all the news it's all the news
we finished something ladies and
gentlemen put your hands together the
news is done done and now everybody's
favorite part of the show ladies and
gentlemen this is where you guys get to
be involved man and ask questions of the
Q&A portion of the of the show and as we
do here on fat man beyond we got friends
in high places Brett Deacon is our
friend who works over at 4dx the 4dx
of people build a cinema experience
where you go see a movie that [ __ ]
you interact with by sitting in this
magic [ __ ] chair if it's snowing in
the movie god damn it it snows in the
[ __ ] theater around you and [ __ ] you
smell what they smell on the movie your
seat moves like the cars move in the
movie if there's a [ __ ] car chase
your chairs moving all over you may even
vomit it's that [ __ ] real 40x
experiences the next level of [ __ ]
attending a movie man you can go see it
if you've never been to one they have in
the big cities not ever everywhere yet
but they're expanding very fast they got
them in Los Angeles here in Los Angeles
that LA live they got a Misha cago they
got I'm in New York and stuff what we do
is thanks to our generous friend deacon
we got five sets of two tickets to give
out to people that ask good questions
man and you can take these tickets and
go to LA live and see I would recommend
seeing a big [ __ ] blockbuster what's
coming next
yeah phantom [ __ ] you could go see
venom what that
I did the you know they're putting
together the blu-ray or the DVD when
they when you make a movie you put
together the [ __ ] DVD and blue-ray
before the movie even comes out so
they're putting the venom blu-ray to bed
now even though the movies not out they
have to put together all the special
features so I had done special features
for the Spider Man DVD they brought me
back for the venom DVD so I just did
that the other day and whatnot the good
news though is that in order to do that
they have to tell you some [ __ ] about
the movie and I learned some [ __ ] about
the movie made me very [ __ ] excited
and really like that's it there take my
[ __ ] money and [ __ ] so not only is it
like the hardy performance is like
that's what I signed on for but they've
got [ __ ] in the movie where I was like
oh [ __ ]
alright you got me you [ __ ] got me I
was always in though so yeah anyway it's
not always in but you're selling me I
know based they showed me nothing but
based on what they told me I was like
that's [ __ ] dope that's [ __ ] dope
they do something in the third act that
everybody's gonna be like wow like it's
a real [ __ ] you moment to the world like
and not [ __ ] you in a bad way just like
[ __ ] you I dare you not to talk about
this on the internet and it's gonna be a
big conference do they just drive into
like theater showing Hamilton and set
watch Hamilton for like half an hour and
that's that's the third act of venom
it's [ __ ] Hamilton who do bad but
people are you serious like yeah like
they have they felt like they had two
really strong first acts and then they
felt like the third act was [ __ ] so they
just all go see Hamilton which is really
good no it looks like it's gonna be
actually pretty damn dope and stuff okay
so yes you can go see venom when it
comes out when is that so anybody know
Tober oh my god it's coming very very
looks like next week alright no not next
week I know time is a consciousness save
these tickets of you wins and you could
go see venom in a 40x theatre I [ __ ]
fully recommend it okay in order to win
these tickets and JC the proprietor of
this here bar he's the one that's gonna
pick the people and bring you up for
and stuff like that he's gonna select
our cures and we're gonna give you were
gonna be the heirs all we ask in order
to qualify for these tickets is the
question has to apply to us both
so don't know no questions for me like
what's it like being Jason muses friend
and no questions for mark about like
what's it like having you know a
grandfather who won't stop using the
word colored so you know something we
can both talk about that later
afterwards not now hit the bar drink
within talk about what's your name young
camper my name is James James everyone
give it up for James what can we do you
for James I'm actually from your neck of
the woods Staten Island so just across
the bay from Jersey there's actually
more news that mark this action you
spoke a few hours ago so you might not
have heard it all right fine you show me
I show how bad I am at my job sorry
Disney actually and out well there's
reports that Disney is acti reaming
service Loki show at Scala which show on
to their streaming service they've got
Disney has an app that's coming soon
it's not out yet
but and some reports refer to it as
Disney play but I don't know it's real
early I guess but whatever it's a
streaming app and that's the one that's
like Jon Favreau's doing a star will
show on and so they announced a Loki
show yes and which a Scarlet Witch show
yes and I made it a live-action a
live-action they actually put in Tom
Hiddleston and also it's also there Wow
yeah I guess they got a little Joseph DC
with it wait what yeah that's real
they're making a show with those people
playing those characters yes well both
their characters and Fanny was didn't
make it so I guess they have some free
time Oh from infinity war yeah well look
come back let's stop kidding like it's
all we agree there's a Santa Claus and
[ __ ] all those heroes are coming back
but more importantly yes they [ __ ]
somehow convinced Tom and Elizabeth to
be on a [ __ ] TV show saying Kevin
Feige is a
get to he's like producing it yes oh my
god they are gonna kill Netflix dude
like that's what it's basically the
whole world is gonna come down to
Netflix and that [ __ ] Disney Channel
because not only do they have all the
Disney that you want to see like [ __ ]
hey it's Moana a thousand times and
whatnot I'm [ __ ] Bedknobs and
Broomsticks
but they're gonna do [ __ ] like that
where it's like if you want to see
[ __ ] elizabeth olsen playing the
[ __ ] Scarlet Witch on an ongoing
series give us your [ __ ] money
after that app thatis a smart they say
they want to focus on secondary avenger
characters that don't have their
standalone movies read the article is
its from oh my god there's a picture of
Tom and [ __ ] Elizabeth yeah alright
let's see breaking news who is rioting
from variety the entertainment giant is
in early development on an ambitious
plan for a number of limited series
centered limited series okay you're not
selling it I just got to excitement into
it Disney is enlisting Earth's Mightiest
Heroes as the company prepares to launch
its upcoming streaming service why they
don't pay either of us the entertainment
giant is an early development on an
ambitious plan for a number of limited
series centered on popular characters
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe oh my
god I would I you don't know how many
dicks I'd suck for that program to make
this [ __ ] happen these series will
likely include shows centered on Loki
and the Scarlet Witch along with other
beloved superheroes who have yet to
appear in their own standalone movies
this is so [ __ ] smart Marvel and
Disney had no comment but that's not a
denial no Wow there's an important
distinction from all other Marvel small
screen efforts however the actors who
portrayed these heroes and villains and
the Avengers films and their spin-offs
such as Tom Hiddleston and Elizabeth
Olsen are expected to play them in the
streaming shows what a wonderful world
we live in
I know everyone's mad about how things
are going politically but this makes it
all better
just give me bread and circuses oh my
god this is such a smart idea Marvel
Studios will produce the shows and Kevin
Feige the Guru of all things MCU is
expected to take a hands-on role in
their development the pricey gamble with
one of the crown jewels of the Disney
film Empire is a sign of how much the
company has riding on its
direct-to-consumer platform and then
they go into that that is not a pricey
gamble like that would if that that
would make me sign up if I wasn't
already like aw I'm already signed up I
want that [ __ ] but like that
that's [ __ ] that's crazy we live in a
world where the like we're gonna make
shows about those characters that you
[ __ ] love that you pay cash money to
go see the theatre and stuff and it's
gonna probably tie together like it's
gonna be like you know like it's almost
as if they're like agents of shield as
if it was part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe or any of the Netflix shows or
something like that oh my god that's so
[ __ ] smart I really hope the Loki
show is a is a sitcom where where he
adopts two black kids who have to like
keep him from getting in trouble because
he's the god of mischief so it's just a
bunch of like wookie I have a pitch okay
different Lok hey that man is mommy now
the world don't move to the beat of just
wasn't drunk would my grant for you may
not be rapper sir but man is born is a
man of means that what it is yes then
along comes - they got nothing but the
jeans
there's wearing jeans oh okay I think
are we just figuring this out together
30 years later it's like it's all about
the wig man is born they're singing
about mr. Drummond yes and he's a man of
means and their long arms - they got
nothing but the genes somebody look it
up see yeah that's right that could be
being naked
they got different intros it takes
different strokes we got different
strokes to rule the world
I don't think it's to rule the world as
yeah it takes different strokes to move
the world I love the world kind of
hippie-dippie [ __ ] is that
domination what kind of capital as
[ __ ] as yours man like a stupid
strokes to rule these [ __ ] people
it's the Iron Throne but come on all
right wait a second how do we get onto
that it's my fault I pitched the sitcom
and you said different low current loads
and then we started singing oh and then
but [ __ ] what a great gift you just
gave us yeah do you have a question too
because you deserve number one you're
getting tickets just for telling us
about that show took a huge [ __ ] jump
thank you my question is based on that
news what other stuff would you like to
just do one I that I think I do okay
I mean what a great question so you also
went tickets for that but like now the
sky's the limit
like Mewtwo asked me this before I'd
read that story and if even if you said
do you think I'll ever make it or in
your accident do you ever think they
make a Loki show I would I would be like
what hear your [ __ ] mind and I would
berate you for 10 minutes about how
industry stupid you were and then you
could have just showed me your phone and
I would have been like sir
I bend my knee to you I would never have
bet that so now that that's a reality
who do I want to see from the Marvel
Universe get their own standalone I'm
tempted to say fan OHS but that's what
infinity what war was the Thanos
standalone movie no no from it's got to
be from it's not like which character
you want to see it's got to be like the
template here is they'll take one of the
characters from your favorite movies and
make some shows about them so who who
oh oh yes
Corrigan what was his name meek meek
Corgan me I've watched that especially
because that guy's like legit
entertainment I could tyka like you
watch him in the behind the scenes and
[ __ ] and that's him playing that
character and you know he ain't gonna
cost a lot of money like you know
elizabeth Olsen yeah and Tom Huddleston
listen they're gonna [ __ ] their agents
are gonna blink you better pay through
the nose and Disney's like we can
because our nose is as big as a mouse's
we're Disney and so they'll pay for it
but him you know they'll be like we'll
give you two books and like you know
because he's not a known actor and [ __ ]
but he will be if they make that [ __ ]
show
that's not one artificial goo Nova Corps
man that's right because they killed
them all off an infinity war with one
line where he's just like they're all
dead now you know which really it all
negates guardians a galaxy their entire
adventure is just gone because of that
so yeah I would see Nova Corps man I
would have spent more time in that world
Hulk of course definitely Falcon maybe
we see enough of him I feel like not
like too much but like I don't feel like
we're missing out Hawkeye oh come on
someone actually posted a meme yeah
didn't they take like remember in the
middle of a age of Ultron they showed us
a whole episode of the Hawkeye show and
nobody wanted to watch it we all tried
to change the channel but it was a movie
so we had to sit through it like home
improvement but with Hawkeye is like I
don't need then yeah the Hawkeye show
I'd be interested in is like open an
episode he gets killed and we spend the
rest of the episodes everyone going like
he was a pretty good guy yeah and then
they go on some adventure and chill I
mean pointless when you're fighting a
mad Titan but okay sure yes if you have
one if they can't get into the movie
maybe
gambit would be a good TV show whoo
candid but again this is like just your
you talk about taking Marvel characters
yeah but this time yeah a big-budget I
don't think they're gonna do
I don't like this is smart because
they're like we know these characters
are proven so we'll spend 50 million
bucks making a Loki [ __ ] show because
we know you like Loki you wouldn't take
that risk with like well we hope you
like gambit you know what I'm saying
even though they own those characters
now I got a smart player who do you got
Winter Soldier you could totally [ __ ]
guy I personally that wouldn't be my cup
of tea I'd watch it of course but like
that would never be the first character
but you're absolutely right all those
missions mm-hmm and you could jump him
around the Marvel Universe and jumping
around history and Chile all the awful
[ __ ] that he's done over the years and
has been fighting against his
programming and yes he seems to need to
be recalibrated after every mission and
so what's the one where he almost got
the furthest away and then they [ __ ]
pull him back in and the tragedy of
what's the one where he fell in love yet
his entire lost world is wiped away by a
man who yes the first Black Panther King
to Chaka
that'd be I mean look anything black
panther but that was so smart right cuz
you can go like we number one ain't
gonna be as expensive we saw the suit
and it looked cool enough it'll totally
work and everybody understands like yeah
this was back in the 90s or whatever
that's a good idea
give me two chocolate whoo and it allows
you to bring Rooker back and bring the
yondu back to life because you're
telling old stories and [ __ ] the this
Sylvester Stallone guardians that we saw
yondu when the Ravagers yeah yes yes all
right [ __ ] that's great I haven't put
one up but I mean I like all of these
I'm trying to take it
like yeah you haven't lost me with a
single one let me think who do I like
who have I liked and ant-man Aunt May
Aunt May she counts man she's in the
cinematic universe do I want to watch I
mean I like I like Marisa Tomei a lot
but I don't know if I want to watch and
it you know what though in the right
hands and [ __ ] they're like know what
I'm saying they're like hey man we're
taking at man we're Sex in the City
English [ __ ] I'm on board in the right
hands I'm totally on board but who would
I'd like to see
turns out I'm glad I'll go betters dance
I'm gonna [ __ ] my way around Queens oh
man
let's try it could call it the queen of
Queens let me see who viola you know
alright there's a here's a whoo-hoo
warriors three from tour they are cool
characters but they're also at the back
of my list yet Valkyrie oh yes but to be
fair I say give her her own movie that's
true here here's a deep bench pitch okay
but I loved his [ __ ] performance and
he was a one-and-done
unless you count some of the video short
afterwards Justin Hammer from Iron Man 2
the great oscar-winning Sam Rockwell I'd
watch a few episodes of that as well
that'd be that'd be my that'd be my
contribution they'd say no but that
would be the one I would say you want
the tickets give it up for Maya's
gentlemen
whoa oh my god that made me so [ __ ]
happy
like I'm just my heart is flying I'm
like oh my god they're gonna put amazing
things on that [ __ ] app that's nuts
hey guys how you doing how are you man
what's your name Elsa man I'm Dane
what is a Dane Dane everyone give it up
add a back-to-back flash shirt now it's
weird how so you walk in but it's like
it's so good yes are we in the smell
style popcorn and other people's farts
in cinemas in Australia so yeah it's
pretty awesome people are weird but you
know how it is so I got a question for
you guys just regarding the shake-up of
the DC Universe just regarding the
recasting of your boy Affleck and Henry
Cavill mm-hm and I'm just wondering who
you guys would choose as the younger
versions that they're planning to recast
great easy question number one you're
gonna win tickets for that let me see
younger you say keying in on younger for
sure that's saying yeah and let's take
the players who are kind of in the game
off the board right like we've all heard
that Jon Hamm is like hey I'll play
Batman and [ __ ] like who's dick - I
gotta suck - make that [ __ ] happen I
want to see that but we'll remove him
from the equation because you're saying
younger right who plays who do I pick to
play Batman who do I pick to replace who
do I pick to play Batman who do I pick
to play superman superman and batman
batman superman superman and Beth Clark
Clark and Bruce Bruce and Clark Kent and
Wayne billionaire and mild-mannered
reporter sons of Martha
you know what [ __ ] you yeah I had just
finally forgotten that [ __ ] you're
bringing it all back up all right let's
see here
who do I like who's who do I like let's
start there girl over there Superman
whoo
there's this kid I don't know if you've
seen him before Henry Cavill I really
think he's [ __ ] got some pretty good
it's pretty strong I'll be honest with
you when they when they said Michael B
Jordan the other day I was like yes do
ya do it when I was a kid and I and it's
not even a new like [ __ ] progressive
idea when I was working on Superman in
1996 Will Smith was floated at Superman
and I was like oh my god [ __ ] do it
and to be fair that came from John
Peters John Peters is like Will Smith
should play this role and I was like
[ __ ] my face Will Smith is jor-el if
Michael B Jordan plays [ __ ] Superman
can I come see your movie sir I'm
[ __ ] over them oh my god what a great
idea
so I'll borrow and say Michael B Jordan
is Superman because that's a great idea
who do I want to see his Batman young
Batman who do I like I love Ryan Gosling
so I'd watch him in anything but I don't
know if I'd rather see him be Bruce
Wayne / Batman or like the Joker like
you know he's a real good actor he might
take that role and [ __ ] run with it
and do something else I don't know if
you want to take the world's greatest
actor and put them into that role where
half the time it's a stuntman anyway so
you just have to find somebody doesn't
have to be the world's greatest but has
to be somebody charismatic somebody who
can carry the costume and cape and stuff
and younger hmm I got a Superman I know
if you do it who Chris Pine
I mean he's in the DC Universe already
you know you're not making his hair
black are you just leaving a blonde
just leave him who he is blonde Superman
you know dirty blonde Superman you'll
catch a lot of [ __ ] on the internet for
that apparently yeah I mean not as much
as Michael B Jordan is Superman because
I've caught that [ __ ] from the internet
don't you imagine Michael B Jordan is
like man I lived through this [ __ ] with
Fantastic Four you want me to go through
this again
but yeah sure look I love Chris Pine so
I'll watch him and do anything charming
yeah very true and I think that that
sort of charm helps carry that yeah yeah
he's big enough gotta be warm as [ __ ]
right yeah like here like Chris Pratt
seems like an ideal Superman kind of in
terms of like personality seems like a
big Catholic kid likes everybody and
stuff like that
I mean damn it can we have Chris's
Krasinski is a great [ __ ] pole man
Krasinski has like a Chris Reeve thing
going on excellent [ __ ] job Krasinski
is a really good [ __ ] pole and you
let him direct that [ __ ] as well but you
make him put dialogue in it this time
yeah that's a good idea Krasinski is
good so you buy him a Superman yeah I
buy him he's got a he's got a doughy
face true like this is [ __ ]
from Krypton nobody said you can't be
doughy and [ __ ] like it's Earth's Yellow
Sun that gives him his power in fact you
know as a guy who's been a man of girth
most of his life I would like to see if
that Superman he's fat cuz he's cut as
[ __ ] he is there's something else
somewhere John Krasinski's like fat [ __ ]
you he said don't waste did you see me
yeah there's your mother's face it's a
little like lumpy and delicious and not
super I'm not like chiseled and [ __ ]
heroic but I could be argued otherwise
it was Chris Reeve chiseled looking in
the face and you hit a good chair yeah
great [ __ ]
Minnie that [ __ ] Chris Reeve over
there though yeah he was dreaming yeah I
guess you're right he had a pretty
strong chin all right it's a Batman who
do I want as a young Batman who do i
watch who do I like what programs are
watched I'm like who dead [ __ ]
good hmm I don't know if you'll ever get
another Affleck near that roll man
a Edgerton whoo-hoo no legit joel
edgerton men interesting joel edgerton
is that the kid who was in the Kingsmen
movies yeah no it's tearin Edgerton then
who's 9 I that
yeah the King Oh Joel Edgerton directed
the gift or gift or whatever who's a
warrior with Tom Hardy which is great
yes I love that maybe there's amazed
everyone puts you know yeah and he's
always like a really good actor he was
in loving with what's-your-face ruth
negga yeah yeah yeah I mean again if
you're going like good actor mmm there's
a good choice because again you put a
mask on the end on that guy half the
time he take joel edgerton go like this
yeah you know and he's got a cool black
outfit on maybe you sell it maybe better
as a feeling a thing I think so like I
definitely lean into him being playing
more of a villainous role [ __ ] Milo
Ventimiglia oh oh oh what a boy from
this is us and heroes back in the day
yeah yeah all right fair enough
fairly interesting I think you're on the
right path though Michael B Jordan I
think you've derailed me completely
because I'm really trying to do this and
it's not like anyone's paying me but I'm
like no no no we can't do anything until
we cast future bad
I know they keep saying like Jake
Gyllenhaal I've always liked him yeah it
meets a but I don't know if I'm just
like oh he's got dark hair like Bruce
Wayne like here man like here all right
this ain't like you know nobody's gonna
be like oh my god like you discovered
him and [ __ ] but you know who'd make an
awesome [ __ ] Bruce Wayne and Batman
Chris Hemsworth hey yeah you know what
I'm saying like something made Thor work
he's in the new men in black - yes he is
we come from seeing him in there's a
soap called home in a way back home
and it's real like a bold and the
beautiful ask is that where he came from
yeah so we're like Hemsworth is what
because his brother went for Liam went
for Thor as well so there were two going
against they were both competing both
Emsworth were up yeah were tried to be
Thor he's still man you just looking at
me and he and also like just took a
character we're in the comics I was
never a Thor guy and he made me [ __ ]
fall in love with that character and
they and it was not right away it wasn't
like oh [ __ ] I think it's Avengers where
I started to go like this guy's [ __ ]
funny once they stop making him be old
for which some people online are like
but I like old Thor and I [ __ ] get it
but like I like the I like this version
where he's self-aware and he can play
into his [ __ ] charm and be funny not
just like I was sold and Odin's son
sweareth and [ __ ] like that yeah let me
let me let me connect can I tweak this
question yes if you could cast anybody
independent of time pretend you you had
a [ __ ] time machine a casting time
machine yes you can cast anybody
throughout Hollywood history ever not
Jon Hamm because we know that who would
you cast for those two guys if I get to
cast Batman across time yes
Robert Shaw playing a young Robert Shaw
from a man for all seasons the one who
played a young Henry the eighth as Bruce
Wayne Robert Shaw's the guy who played
Quentin jaws so imagine a younger
version of him as a driven [ __ ] Bruce
Wayne
III would cast him that was one of my
favorite performances of all time him
jaws but his entire career is really
worth watching think about the intensity
of his performance in Black Friday
remember that movie as Batman Black
Sunday sorry Black Friday I was thinking
about shopping black Sunday yeah like
that's a guy who could totally [ __ ] be
a really gripping Batman I mean there's
obvious choices like hey what about
Robert De Niro is [ __ ] Bruce Wayne and
[ __ ] cuz taxi driver is a version of
Batman to some degree right but across
time as Superman Cary Grant does very
romantic choice but no you're wrong but
very sweet
let's see man Andre the Giant Hunter the
Giant just make a statement man you're
like this look at him any super [ __ ] I'm
on the brute squad you are the brute
squad whoo yeah god I got no imagination
well I don't know Robert Shaw was a good
pole that's not bad I wanted to I mean
all right here man this is ain't gonna
be a popular call but Tom Cruise circa a
few good men I'd get behind that I think
he has to be yeah he's like Tom Cruise
kind of carries the you know in Mission
Impossible it's always like against the
government shadow government [ __ ] like
yeah but he has the kind of like you
know
aw shucks and glint in his eye he
reminds me of Curt Swan Superman - Curt
Swan Superman and comics booted
periodically at the end of a book or the
end of it adventure literally look at
the viewer as if he was looking down the
barrel of the camera and wink and so Tom
Cruise could kind of pull that off his
the ability a thing to also we've seen
him fly he jumps on couches and that's
fair his ability to cast a spell on you
I think you you always say Tom Cruise
get out of here then when you see him in
something you're like ah yeah that's
true
that's what about you casting through
history history I think
Burt Reynolds foresee mustache no
mustache mustache so we finally get a
Superman with a mustache somewhere Henry
cattles like [ __ ] you yeah had a
Superman with a puss [ __ ] it
alright so Burt Reynolds a Superman and
they tried to get him to do that one I
know yeah and Clint Eastwood that's
Bruce Wayne well what year like what era
Dirty Harry I'm act I'd no I think he'd
go like the man with no name
oh good pull good or maybe Charles
Bronson I think Watson could also be a
really good Bruce Wayne all right and if
we're casting against now we're just
playing like you know who I want to see
I'm gonna say circa glory Denzel
Washington ooh
young [ __ ] like you know he's still a
great actor but when he was just [ __ ]
like a young man and stuff being driven
Bruce Wayne um all right yeah we're done
we could do this man you got a great one
tickets man excellent job excellent job
all right JC take us someplace else
what's your name I'm camper hi guys my
name is Robert Robert everyone give it
up for Robert Robert so that a tickets
with your name on it Robert if you get
this right okay so I'm a big fan I love
the show because since the very first
day but I'm starting to make friends I'm
been in LA for about two years and I'm
making friends who actually believe it
or not aren't called book fans which is
completely new for me why would you come
from I'm originally from Oregon Eugene
Oregon and so that's a college town not
is not a big comic book community there
no my friends were huge film buffs
we're big compact fins but when you move
to a city where you know where
absolutely nobody you know you kind of
get to get out there and make some
friends which is why I love coming here
so much best place to make friends
- geek drink and be merry right here as
a scum and villainy cantina give it up
for JC built a fine establishment that's
cool now I like I'd like to hear that
yeah it's a nice place to meet people
and meet new people and [ __ ] like that
and bond over similar subject matter of
the things below yeah but Eugene's
beautiful I've been there I've done
shows there and that's where they shot
Animal House oh yeah when I was in town
last time I went to the place where
Delta house used to be and they've torn
it down and replace it with a business
office but there's this plaque on a
stone that memorializes the house that
used to be there and it has like
paragraphs full of history going back to
like the turn of the century or 1700s
when the house was first built and who
lived there and [ __ ] and then there's
one sentence at the end that says they
also shot a movie called Animal House
and we have to burn it down I get for
college kids that movies pretty
legendary we go we celebrated actually
every year at graduation we do the the
shout dance but my question is you know
meeting people who don't know comics I'm
getting to kind of see people discover
this for the first time which is a bit
new for me so it has me wondering um all
of us at some points had a moment where
we kind of found our fandom and we
discovered wow I'm not the only one who
likes this for me it was with comics and
I'm a huge wrestling fan so those are my
two fandoms that I kind of discovered in
their fans everywhere yeah well now it's
the best time to be a fan because it's
not quite as taboo as it is in years
past but my question is do you remember
when you found your fandom or a group of
friends where you realized wow I'm not
the only one who likes this what a great
question you're gonna win tickets give
it up for them that's all
like let me see when I'll do my fandoms
in order that I remember from childhood
from zero to like four it's Snoopy
Snoopy is the love of my life and I love
the peanuts and stuff but Snoopy if I
get my hands on Snoopy anything that's
it but there was no like we're in the
Snoopy fan club or anything like that
you know so I didn't get a sense that I
knew other people like Snoopy I knew I
wasn't alone they had [ __ ] cartoons
on once a year during the holidays and
[ __ ] but there was no like we all got
together and talked about like why is
that dog so shitty to that kid with
cancer the bald boy you know that would
come later in life so fandom goes Snoopy
hands off to Batman and I discovered
Batman through Adam West's Batman on TV
of course watching Batman 66 what we now
call Batman 66 and also reading comic
books at a place many of the barbers
where my dad would take me to get my
hair cut they had the TV in the waiting
room and [ __ ] and under the TV who was
newspapers and comic books for kids and
so that's where I started reading Batman
aside from watching him on Super Friends
and seeing him on TV is Adam West then I
started like reading about his
adventures a completely different Batman
than the previous two that I'd known but
it was all kind of in the same quarter
that began a lifelong fandom that
results in this [ __ ] show as well
that fandom handed off to the Six
Million Dollar Man I was a huge [ __ ]
fan had the doll and [ __ ] like that or
action figure but he was a [ __ ] tall
doll I loved that world so much I also
had the Bionic Woman doll and stuff like
that but the only other fans I knew I
knew it had fans people must watch it
you know cuz it was on TV and [ __ ] but
there was no like internet below who
[ __ ] loves the Bionic Woman man Jaime
Sommers like I'm mother [ __ ] hard you
just you know my brother liked it so
that was good enough and [ __ ] then the
next fandom was Star Wars so I see Star
Wars in 1977 and that was the first time
that I knew
other people like something that I liked
and not just because hey it was on TV
and we both happen to watch it or
something like that like first time I
heard about Star Wars was through
somebody who was a fan in my class who
had gone to see it and stuff it was I
wasn't an early adopter or anything I
saw it pretty late in its run like it
came out in May I probably saw it by
July after I like convinced my parents
like you have to vote good take me
everyone is seeing it but me so fandom
is what introduced me to it and then
when I went the place was packed and I
[ __ ] loved the movie and [ __ ] and
then you'd come out of the movie and
talk to others about it one of the my
best friendships in life I talked about
on SModcast again this week the episode
that just dropped his kid I've group
grew up across the street from Pete King
he lived in Brooklyn in the city but his
family would come down the shore over
the summer so they stayed in this
bungalow across the street from our
house and stuff and Pete King was little
yet bit younger than me like maybe two
years but he had every [ __ ] Star Wars
toy imaginable so a mutual fandom
created a friendship that lasted for
years Pete died years later and stuff
tragically is struck by a taxi cab in
Manhattan but the friendship was born
out of it most of my friendships a
childhood were born out of like mutual
liking of things and fandom the first
real like oh [ __ ] there's a lot of us
Kurds meet like beyond just you know all
the people in my school or my class that
know this movie or all the people that
you would see like on news reports where
they show you lines around the building
for Star Wars or something when I joined
the Star Wars fan club in 1980 that was
when I was fully cognizant of like
there's a network there's a bunch of us
like you know I know that people that I
knew there were people that just go see
movies like you know all that was a
movie good and they go on with their
[ __ ] lives and there's a difference
between those people and me and the
people in the Star Wars fan club like it
didn't end when the credits rolled like
we kept talking about it like and we
talked about it to the point where our
parents would be like you [ __ ] shut
up like we're in church you know so like
it was it that's it's got to be Star
Wars that's where I was cognizant of
like
part of a larger thing and I share
terminology with only people that
[ __ ] know it and stuff and knowledge
was power like if you met other Star
Wars fans and you can name [ __ ]
characters that weren't like the big
three or something like that
it's got to be Star Wars for me you was
there I'm just there is a quote gave not
to get super nerdy but there's a
documentary a really great one called
comic-book superheroes unmasked we talk
about comic book shops and how they're
kind of I don't know how they are
anymore but for the longest time it was
almost built as kind of a cave where
people could come in and so adults or
Outsiders wouldn't come in and go what's
this this is silly so what was there a
moment for comics and with compa fans
specifically I loved comics when I was a
kid I was a marvel zombie more than a DC
kid I loved Batman but I loved the
Marvel Comics more their characters were
way more vibrant and [ __ ] interesting
to me and stuff Batman I would get
deeper into later in life in terms of
like all the pay those of this
characters what's really appealing and
stuff so I was a Marvel kid and let me
see what was the comics what was the
moment that I realized like this was
bigger say your question again because I
had an answer and it's slow where did
you find your comics fandom like what
pulled you to like oh there's other I
got loves this thank you beautifully
done when I was a kid there was nothing
like that that's why I was able to let
it go
I liked comics but I couldn't stand up
for him like as I entered high school so
I was like uh something kids do and [ __ ]
like that that seemed to be the common
consensus at large like comics those are
for [ __ ] kids
there was no there's one kid I knew in
high school - you know what - because
now I'm being unfair I could have been a
comics geek in high school but I wasn't
brave enough well
of james.byrne drew he was an excellent
artist and he knew all the characters
that can draw them and [ __ ] like that so
the old comic book fan and me whenever I
saw James John I was like holy [ __ ] man
you're John Captain America holy [ __ ]
man you drawing the [ __ ] Falcon
you're drawing Human Torch and stuff he
kept up with comics I'd let him go in
high school because I wanted to get laid
he was he he he embraced them still and
Eugene Simpson was another kid who was
still into comics so I could talk to
those guys about [ __ ] that I used to
love but they never drew me back in they
were never like you should go [ __ ]
you should go to the comic book store
with us or anything like that
Walter Flanagan the guy from comic book
man one of my dearest friends in the
world he was the one that like
introduced true fandom into my heart
when I got into comics again after high
school a nightly 88 early 89 he was my
comics guru the fan I've told the story
many times but I'll tell it here and
I'll try to make it quick Walter didn't
talk to me for the first 10 months that
I worked with him at the Highlands
Recreation Center me and Walter Flanagan
Brian Johnson Jason Mewes we all met in
the service of caring for children isn't
that [ __ ] up we cared for kids at this
after-school program the recreation
center and [ __ ] so I worked with Walter
for months he never [ __ ] spoke to me
and I one day asked the boss says I
can't even [ __ ] talk to Walt what do
you talk to Walt about he never talked
to me and my boss Timmy Hill he goes he
likes comics comic books I was a comics
nice read comic books when I was kid all
right I [ __ ] I'm gonna talk to him
about comics so we were playing foosball
me and him one day with two kids we
weren't even playing together we were
just had kids playing and they were
young so each of us had go like he
Walters playing goal I was playing goal
and the two kids were playing but if you
play [ __ ] booze ball kids it's a
boring ass long game because they can't
see over the table number one and all
they want to do is spend the [ __ ]
dudes in jail like that so it gives you
a lot of time to talk so I finally got
up the courage to say to Walt Flanagan I
was like hey man I understand you like
comic books and he's like yeah and he
just kept in the game like he was not
[ __ ] interested in anything I had to
say and I was like well you know I still
read comic books like all the time
and but then I quit when I got to high
school because I wanted to get laid and
that was the first time he looked at me
in ten months of working there he
[ __ ] looked up he goes what the [ __ ]
does that mean and I was like oh yeah no
well just means that like most people
think that comics are for kids he goes
what [ __ ] people say that and I was
like won't [ __ ] not me I assure you
but I've heard it said by others and he
reached into his back pocket and he
pulled out a rolled-up trade paperback
of The Dark Knight Returns and he handed
it to me and he goes you take that home
and you read that right now and he's
goes you come back tomorrow you tell me
if you think comic books are for kids
and I was so [ __ ] stunned like I
didn't have a response mostly because I
was like he had a whole book in his back
pocket this whole time and a trade
paperback is pretty [ __ ] large it's
not like a little paper bag that fits
back there so he was pock committed I
was like that's impressive
he just [ __ ] roams this land like a
gunslinger ever ready you know to be
like [ __ ] ignorance knowledge you
know and target so I read it at home and
I went back in the next day and I was
like my god this is [ __ ] comic books
now like this is crazy shit's
unbelievably [ __ ] good I want and if
this is comic books I'm gonna start
buying comics again man where do you buy
these store I'm gonna go with you please
take me and he was like yes that is
comic book so the next time somebody
tells you the comics are for kids he's
like you show him this image of Batman
breaking this [ __ ] spine that's not
for children that's metal and he taught
me how to like stand up for [ __ ] you
like like you know when people talk
about me now - like oh my god he's like
you know like on Twitter I was like [ __ ]
I love this trailer and people like you
[ __ ] page he'll like not at all it's
just like hey man I [ __ ] love this
trailer Walter taught me to embrace that
to never [ __ ] apologize for liking
something like Walter's like so I don't
give a [ __ ] that people don't like comic
books you're trying to tell me they
think I'm stupid cuz I read The Watchmen
I think there's [ __ ] stupid because
they've never read The Watchmen how
about that No
like oh my god he sticks by his guns and
[ __ ] like that that was impressive to me
and like fandom at all costs these are
my colors so if you insult my the thing
I like you're insulting me and so I
learned that from him but he's more
aggressive about it like [ __ ] you I like
this I'm more inviting I'm the guy
that's just like oh my god I found this
thing I gotta share it with you it's
[ __ ] dope have you seen this Captain
Marvel trailer and everyone's like yeah
we're here on the world and the planet
so of course we've all [ __ ] seen it
but some [ __ ] you can tell people about
they've never heard about before it's
like to share [ __ ] that's [ __ ] fandom
and I got that from Walter man the idea
of like don't be [ __ ] ashamed of the
[ __ ] you like just [ __ ] share it man
loud and proud it could be a heart can
be a hard lesson no it was easy coming
from that [ __ ] guy you have some [ __ ]
to say a little bit know like fandom for
me was it's a thing you engage with like
I am a fan of a bunch of stuff and have
been ever since I was like five or six
and Star Wars was the first real thing
that I engaged with like I love this I
want all the things but it was never I
never joined a fan club I never went to
like one of the meetings I never got the
pin for showing up for anything I never
drank the stale coffee outside the
meetings in the church basement we all
talked about Star Wars
they have groups like that different
things now
so absolutely my childhood in mind my
adolescence is just littered with this
[ __ ] that I love like I love Bugs Bunny
and I love dandy cat books and I loved
[ __ ] Mad Magazine and then I loved
the Dukes of Hazzard because I loved
Evel Knievel and then I realized Dukes
of Hazzard is like emotionally racist so
maybe not that and then Knight Rider
shows up and gives me everything I loved
about Dukes of Hazzard was a car jumping
over [ __ ] he talks to you and not nearly
as racist so I'm solid
writer you know and and and I believe
that was their commercial when it first
give a Nightrider
not nearly racist maybe we don't put the
Confederate flag on the roof or this car
and my mom didn't understand why I love
[ __ ] dukes of hazzard so much I just
couldn't get it like what what do you
love about the show
there's flaming arrows they're jumping
[ __ ] they're rebels fighting against the
law she's like alright I'm hoping you
grow out of this phase we're gonna have
a rough conversation a little bit if you
don't meanwhile grandpa's like there's
no such thing as dinosaurs but I didn't
truly engage in a fandom till until I
went to comic-con for the first time
what year is that that would have been
like 2002 I think because again I've
been fans of a bunch of [ __ ] but I never
went to like a Star Trek convention I
loved my comic book store but it was a
relatively solitary pursue that a couple
friends in high school but we weren't
like charter members of anything we just
liked reading comics we liked playing
D&D
we liked watching dune too many times
and it was like because we were the only
ones who could talk the language of doom
to anybody else because nobody else
[ __ ] watch dune but it was until I
got to comic-con and I saw people
gathered all together by a thing that
they loved you could walk down any
[ __ ] hallway in there and you just
Dumble into a room filled with people
who loved a thing and decided to come
from all over the world to be in that
room at that moment with those people
because they all loved the same thing
and I had never engaged in it that way
until I went to comic-con for the first
Center and found the people some of
which I had known in other walks of life
who happen to be there because they
happen to go [ __ ] we walk across the
street from each other 3,000 miles away
and you're stumbling out of this [ __ ]
Gundam thing just you're loved and
there's an awesome dude good for you but
and still that is that for me is my
fandom is fandom at this point my fandom
is the love people have for the [ __ ]
that maybe sets them apart that maybe
they never engage with truly then maybe
makes them outcasts but they all love
the same thing and they love being
together because there were strengthened
numbers there is we are tribal people
you know for better and for worse and
watching those tribes all gather in
under the happiest [ __ ] place in the
world for those four days that is that
is when I feel the most joy of being a
fan is watching other fans and watching
the safe space that all those fans
create for each other so yeah it wasn't
until I became a grown-ass man I engaged
in fandom in a real way I don't know if
that answers your question
very much well a great question as
previously stated you win tickets well
done man pleasure
all right JC another victim
what's your name captain Nick everyone
give it up for Nick hey Jersey Jersey in
the house what part Bergen County oh
[ __ ] I was up north I once played street
hockey on a Bergen County indoor stunt
indoors surrounded Frank it was outdoor
but it like had official boards up and
[ __ ] when we play it in street hockey at
home we put up I didn't adapt stack put
up wooden boards around the tennis court
to use as boards because there's a lot
of ball slapping if you slap a [ __ ]
ball on a fence it just sticks and I'm
just a lot of balls laughs hell yeah man
that's why I like field so we went once
up to Bergen County and played at this
like [ __ ] amazing hockey rink that
was made for outdoor hockey for inline
skates and [ __ ] like that almost like
you know oh my god this part they got so
much money what state is this it's like
your state [ __ ] like we're in
the same state but they never built us
one of those we had to kind of build our
own anyway that's all I got for Bergen
what do you got for me
so if you guys could take any iteration
of any cinematic character DC and marvel
any timeline and do a crossover film for
instance like Keaton Batman with like
Wesley Snipes blade Marvel what would
you do that would be mine by the way
that number one great [ __ ] question
man all right so the idea is we're
crossing over any era comic book movie
yours is Keaton Batman versus Wesley
Snipes blade yeah or Jim Carrey the mask
ooh yeah nobody ever gives
I mean it's so weird the mass was an
amazing comic book based I am really one
of the first good ones and based on like
very close to the source material like
I'd read the book the masked long before
they made the [ __ ] movie it was just
a great Dark Horse book and when they
were making the flood killing they can't
possibly do it and they got pretty
[ __ ] close man but nobody really
talks about it anymore it's strange I
bet you that's a movie that's ripe for
the remaking sooner or later somebody's
gonna be like oh my god we could do so
much more of the facts but Jim Carrey
gave such an amazing performance beat ah
tough to top that so maybe not okay but
that's the idea the premises movies that
have existed and we cross them over you
go first
I will go World War 2 era Captain
America which movie First Avenger do
that plus the Rocketeer oh I will do I
will do Nazi [ __ ] fighting same
director Joe Johnson made both of those
movies that's right same to Nazi [ __ ]
punch in in the air and on the ground
wow that's
I'm never gonna beat that that's [ __ ]
god that's good I was immediately like
just thinking of the usual suspects but
you grab not that movie but like [ __ ]
Batman versus who but you went [ __ ]
classy all right let me think [ __ ] I
can't top it and now I'm trying to
that's impossible so it's gonna be
catastrophic failure if I try so think
keV be logical any era what do you love
all right all right all right all right
oh I got it all right it's coming heavy
it's not gonna be popular but
thematically tonally it's gonna it's
gonna match up a little bit not saying
they're both same quality at all
lots of caveats yeah I just don't want
the internet to be like can you believe
of this idiot said this week you know
but I I this is just I think tonally you
could smash these movies together and
it's got to be Marvel DC right or
something or something something
something alright I didn't give it I'm
never gonna beat that so I'm gonna toss
this one out there thor ragnarok batman
forever works part of me was hoping
you're gonna say Thor Ragnarok and
Scooby Doo and Scooby dude you're
talking dog is interesting to me do you
have any more Scooby Snacks God you gave
a good answer though that I would you
can see those two [ __ ] crossover
[ __ ] sorry now you beat me I mean look
at the end of the day [ __ ] that's
good but and and look the question beat
us both it was amazing give it up for a
mani one excellent job well jersey
represents man well done [ __ ] that was
good so good I was [ __ ] had a weak
answer best the comic book crossover
Teen Titans in x-men I agree wonderful
wonderful book alright I've got one last
set of tickets and we got somebody
standing here what's your name my friend
I mean Eugene what is Eugene Eugene I'm
gonna give it up for you Jane you look
sharp Eugene I know look at you did you
come from worked or are you always
dressed to go out like dude I figured
like it's Church got dressed up for
church right yes that's true we are
caught up in the church users well I've
been here a couple times and I was
wearing actually my suit every single
times just like I just feel like
dressing up I just like dressing up but
now that you're wearing the jacket in
like oh man I gotta wear to see you you
like I used to wear a jacket then you
start wearing a jacket now I'm in a suit
what the [ __ ] you gonna wear I gotta get
a tux next week I'll be here in a tux
with tails um what are you what can we
do you for sir uh well I got a question
and a liberal of a gag I've been waiting
to do this like ever since you announced
it but uh so in honor of the fact that
you're so committed to being a vegan I
want to present to you this copy of
Scott Pilgrim vol 3 that has Todd Ingram
in it and I
that all the rest of the moves you make
are well infused with your vegan powers
Thank You Man [ __ ] I know we got a
lot of meat eaters here but thank you
but in our little secret Club this mean
something why why this particular book
does he is he beat yeah yeah he's um so
if you remember this story
he's actually one of the evil boyfriends
and he's a vegan and he gets special
powers he's a vegan
Brendan Ralph's played him in the movie
give at it yeah Alecto [ __ ] thank you
was that the line one one of many um
thank you for this man this means the
[ __ ] world when I get home I'm gonna
show my kid and she'll be like so and
I'll be like I got it cuz I'm a vegan
and she'll cry so thank you man I love
going home and making my kid cry thank
you that means a lot alright what can we
do you for
alright um number one you give me a book
so you win tickets yeah alright um so
like after I watched the suicide like
okay so before sooo so this is like
gonna long thing cuz system Suicide
Squad
okay um before I watched it I was like
super stoked just by looking at the
character art design for like etana
and then I watched the movie and I was
incredibly disappointed and since then
I've been sort of dabbling trying to
make like a like a script or just for
fun like a katana movie um and I feel
kind of guilty sometimes cuz I'm not
Japanese nor a woman so I'm like how
should I go about like writing this sort
of script like what what like what
pitfalls am I not seeing and both of you
have written things with a female lead
so what is that process what if you were
to use your experience like if you
talked to your wives what have you been
able to handle that sort of headspace
when writing that what a great question
give it up and that's [ __ ]
yeah you know I at least did career wise
I came up in an age where you could you
know you could mean chasing a me as a
female very strong female lead but I you
know one could make the argument the
movies not about Alyssa it's really
about Holden so it's still a male point
of view I've never I mean the dogma is a
female lead like Bethany is actually
know the hose you're sweaty yoga hoses
yes that's right thank you for being the
one person that saw it but yes you're
right those are two female leads and
stuff like that I'm trying to I guess I
have I always just assumed in my head
I'm like everything's kind of
male-dominated cuz you're male but I
have kind of gone up to bat a few times
I mean I've always said I feel strong
female characters but I have done some
[ __ ] with female leads where the lead
main character is a woman what did I do
I mean I was always this sounds so
[ __ ] stupid but I was just always
fascinated by women my whole life and
stuff like I'm a guy so I know how guys
think and I knew other guys hung out
with guys and women were the other the
mysterious other and then once I started
becoming friends of them at age like six
or seven Janine white was my first
female friend at age six and stuff and
she was [ __ ] fascinating cuz a she
wasn't a boy and stuff and B she had a
whole different point of view than I'd
ever really heard before I mean my
sister at a point of view but [ __ ]
she's my sister I never listened to it
but Janine was like my first female
friend and put me on the road to like
man [ __ ] like women are way more
interesting than men and not just in the
way of like I'd rather have sex with
them than the men but just they're way
more interesting like they've got
there's a lot going on and [ __ ] and you
know in the in the 70s when we were
growing up they didn't depict that you
know it was very [ __ ] male heavy
culture and stuff so I think because I
grew up with very strong women my high
school friends Janet Peterson Laurie
Murchison Debbie lepay Jane Kurtz very
strong females who were like very in
charge they weren't like you know oh man
they got horrible boyfriends to treat
him bad and [ __ ] they were they they
were they seemed in charge at all times
in some ways everything
male character I write that goes back to
the girls in high school that I grew up
with because that's that's what they
were like when you read about you know
Elissa is definitely informed by Joey
Adams but you know the clerk's female
characters the Mallrats female
characters very informed by the women or
girls that I grew up with in high school
because I was like you know I wasn't the
guy that's like and I dated them all no
though nobody would [ __ ] the fat kid so
like we all became very very tight and
very friendly and stuff so I think
that's where I got the voice from not my
mother by any stretch the imagination
I'm not taking anything away from her
but mom didn't have a particularly like
you know mom got married at age 18 to my
dad and became a housewife like right
out of secretary school and nothing
wrong with this at all and stuff but she
didn't have the liberated like point of
view or whatever you know she was kind
of doing the suburban three kids and
then the small house kind of thing so it
was other women the ones I grew up with
later on ones I'd meet in the real world
my sister later on in life I joke about
like ignoring her stuff she was the one
that introduced me to writing to the
notion that you could just sit down and
start writing I'd found a composition
notebook under her bed and I was like
what is this and she's it was a picture
a drawing of her and her friends
kneeling around a cellar door and stuff
very crude drawing not crude like their
tits were out but crude because she was
a child when she drew it man if I was
like five she was ten at that point so I
said was this and she goes that's a book
I'm writing as what do you mean she's
gone writing a book about me and my
friends would go on an adventure we find
a secret door and we find stuff we go on
adventure and I was so baffled I'm five
years old and I don't know how the world
works and [ __ ] but I know I think I know
what I know and I'm trying to Gaslight
my older sister by going like you can't
write a book you just you can't just
write a book you have to ask the
government and my sisters like why do
you think that and I'm like because we
had to get a library card to get a book
out of the library man the government
has a say and my sister was like you're
in your [ __ ] mind
anybody could do whatever they wanted I
can write anything they want well you
don't have to ask permission right this
don't look like a book from the
but if it get published
it would look like a book from the
library but you don't need permission
you want to write something just start
writing something and I wouldn't be for
years it's not like an that day I wrote
clerks cuz I was five but that stayed
with me years later I would start
writing for fun not because somebody has
signed it in school but because like
this makes me feel good I'm gonna put
words together and see if I can make my
brother laugh so I think my friends
growing up my sister later on the women
that I was romantically were
romantically involved with Joey of
course you know there's no chasing a me
without Joey Adams and then since
marrying Jennifer which is now we've
been together 20 years and stuff she's
informed every female character that
I've written from 1998 forward from like
Jay and Silent Bob strike back forward
people like well Jane Silent Bob strike
back isn't exactly the most like strong
portrait of a woman I mean some woman
falls in love with Jay how [ __ ] dumb
is that like but moving forward like
from there as well Jersey girl clerks to
like Jack and Mary all of that was
informed by by Jen so I think that's
where I got it from that being said you
know I'm not qualified to to I can write
a real strong female lead in a movie but
it's probably better if she's not the
main focus like I'm a male so I know the
male perspective
I should probably lean in toward that
otherwise I'm punching above my weight
class so to speak and tough to explain
the female experience from you know the
perspective of like I've been a man my
whole life and stuff but this is absurd
I read you know you there is there's a
pretty famous picture of Muhammad Ali
when he I think it just won the the gold
medal in Rome and he likes underwater
he's in the pool he submerged in a pool
and he's boxing's going through like his
[ __ ] workout which is fake by the way
he never did that he did it because it's
a photo op the Life magazine
photographer it was like well we got
this kid he's got a bunch of energy in
mom's like I'll get in the pool I'll
pretend to show you how to workout which
he never worked out that way before that
trailer made for an amazing photo op so
this is amazing photo if it's in the
Creed trailer
he's punching underwater and when you
look at that photo it's it's of a guy
sort of going through the motions but
it's harder because he's underwater but
you can't really see the burdens on him
but you know that it's harder than it
would be doing it on land and I imagine
as I have been told time and time again
that you know women in this country
especially women of color in this
country are working twice as hard for
half as much and you never get to see
the burdens that are holding them back
because you as a man really can't
understand what those those handcuffs
are like and so when I'm in drama the
key is finding a character deciding what
they want and burdening them with
hurdles to getting what they want that's
all drama is your hero wants something
they have a target and they want to get
there and you put a bunch of [ __ ] in
their way and make it hard for them to
get there when they get there they win
the day whatever that is oh my god
you're right click every movie and story
I've ever read the Arats like you know
[ __ ] Odysseus wants to go home all he
wants to do is go home what's in the way
10 years of [ __ ] horror and Scylla
and Charybdis and all this mythological
[ __ ] it's and it's the Warriors
which is the same thing that gang just
wants to get back to fun Coney Island
what's in the way every other [ __ ]
gang in New York nice Paul and so when
writing women they want those things to
write they have a goal that they want
they want a thing
deciding whatever that thing is is up to
you but it's realizing that some of the
hurdles for them getting there we can't
see because the world is arrayed against
women in ways they aren't arrayed
against men and so the tonnage of that
weight the the fighting those fights
that we don't always get to see makes
them stronger in ways that men aren't
and resilient in ways that men aren't
and forgiving in ways that men could
never be and so it's it's it's just
realizing that their paths are going to
be different but they want the same
things because they're human people who
want the things that people want they
want one and safety and home
and victory and all of that [ __ ] it's
just figuring that they're packed to get
there will be slightly different and
it's opening yourself up to people in
the world and like hey let me let let's
talk about XY and Z let me see what your
perspective is on a wine see let's let
me read [ __ ] something let me do some
research as a writer if you don't know a
thing you look it up you interview
people you sit down you try and pretend
to walk a mile in those shoes to get a
sense of what that life is like and try
and make that life feel lived in it's
different for me because I write things
that explode and science fiction so I'm
never gonna write like Erin Brockovich
cuz I don't know what that life is like
for that woman but she wants something
and what's in the way of her wanting
those things the system and so her path
is how do I overcome the system by using
everything in my disposal including my
breasts and a male character can't do
that but that woman absolutely can and
so it's figuring out it's it's figuring
out the line of that drama and figuring
out how to make that character feel like
it's somebody you would meet on the
street and I think that it's it's
realizing that women are not just men
with different parts but they are still
human beings who want the same things
that everybody else does but that's just
me and I write [ __ ] that explode so
that's good but I would also add to that
every writer is a thief right like we
just steal from the real world you hear
[ __ ] you know like ooh that's good then
you put it into something and it's not
necessarily you know pay for a and B for
B in terms of like I heard somebody say
smoochy boo cheese once although I did
hear somebody say smoochy boo cheese and
wrote it in a script thankfully it was
the guy that I know said it [ __ ] so if
if that's the case most of the [ __ ] I've
written is influenced by the people that
have been around me they're not all my
thoughts and stuff it's like you've got
to hear those voices in order to pull
them in so if you're having a hard time
I mean this sounds dopey but get
yourself around the character get
yourself around somebody that you know
that matches the character if you're
like I want to write women better start
hanging out with a woman and just be
like download man give me a minute just
start stealing like I'm not in a shitty
don't take her [ __ ] but like steal her
thoughts her mannerisms like the things
she says like the nuances and whatnot
you know we're observers writers have to
be observers first and you only get to a
place where you can write about things
when you [ __ ] studied it long enough
and you're like all right I think I have
a take on this so it just helps to be
around the subject matter find yourself
at a [ __ ] baby shower dude it's not
like if you were right in sci-fi you're
like I don't know what a wookie thinks
like I can't tell you like go find some
wookiees and talk to them and [ __ ] like
they're you got to make some [ __ ] up but
you're talking about like they're like
over half the population or women so you
could probably ask one of them man hey
what would you say you know just
literally be like is what I'm writing
what would be the next thing you'd say
and then they'll call a cop on you and
maybe the next one will be more helpful
I don't know it sounds like we're
talking about them like they're Martians
like we must investigate these women but
you know that's just I all my female
characters are informed by the women
that are around me like that's I can
default to that a criticism I've
received on a lot of [ __ ] I've written
is like all of his female characters
just sound like him but to be fair I get
that criticism on all my characters
still like they all just sound like him
and I've never found that to be
criticism because I think that's the
point it's like if you're an artist you
want people to recognize you and so like
when people like all his characters
sound like Kevin Smith I'm like well
thank God they don't sound like Quentin
Tarantino because he's already doing him
so I'm gonna [ __ ] do me and [ __ ]
that's just a little side note being you
we both answered we both it was a great
question you win [ __ ] tickets getting
[ __ ] tickets
excellent job an excellent [ __ ] suit
my god we've got some good commentary
going some good [ __ ] questions yeah
man
always it is I mean I always say look
good but everyone's favorite part of the
QA but I think it's just my favorite
part I enjoy that part of the show I
love it and and I've been to a number of
q and A's especially living in this town
and sometimes we get invited to
screenings or whatever there's Q&A is
afterwards and all too often those
questions from those crowds are the
worst questions you've ever heard yeah I
am so [ __ ] thankful that this
particular audience is the smartest
[ __ ] audience I've ever seen I would
agree in and that's not just like
greasing the wheels and [ __ ] everybody
paid so [ __ ] them we got their money
this is uh this is more of an
observation you're absolutely right as
always you see things you you see
everything you said you saw something
that I never really noticed before he's
absolutely right in normal Q&A scenarios
the questions tend to be kind of like
like if you're sitting there after a
movie geeky Q&A and somebody gets up to
talk you know though sometimes there's a
question really like come on really why
would you [ __ ] ask that that's never
really happened in this setting I don't
know if it has to do with like the fact
that like you got to ask us both a
question or they've heard previous
episodes and stuff but like no [ __ ]
and not stroking anybody the Q&A part it
I always walk away like it's the last
part of the show and when we leave here
we say goodnight we go outside and
usually the first thing out of my mouth
is like that was [ __ ] fun man we got
some cool [ __ ] going on and so so I'm
legit always enthused by it and never
surprised but now that you mention it I
should be surprised because the standard
Q&A fair isn't normally as good as we
get here so we're breathing rarefied air
it allows us to like look smart and give
great answers but it's starting with
really fantastic questions so thank you
all for playing along man you guys are
smart well done that's all the [ __ ]
show we got man are you satisfied have
you been entertained
we will be back when I'm done shooting
Supergirl which I guess will be like I
think second week in October meantime
check the schedule because mark might be
doing black man beyond right here as a
one-man show and then after that he
follows it up with a one-man show where
he plays Mark Twain as well so but as
soon as I can get back I'll come back
and we'll do this again Mex is my my
favorite things in the world to do
ladies and gentlemen have you had a good
time this evening you do not have that
good time without this establishment man
give it up for JC and scum and villainy
Cantina and we do not have [ __ ] great
conversation otherwise you just be
hearing a lot of [ __ ] Jason Mewes
dick stories we're not for the man
standing next to me ladies gentlemen
give it up for the great mark bernard
enter and that is fat man beyond for
this week man I'm Kevin Smith and I am
more Cronulla tune in next time same bat
time same bat Channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith